Everybody.
This episode of the podcast is
brought to you by 1-800-FLOWERS,
one 800 flowers.com it's almost
mother's Day fuckers. That's right.
It's time to send moms some beautiful
rose is something lovely to let her know
that all that pain when she shot you
out of her vagina was not for, not,
not for, not, you're not
allowed to say that. Oh,
you can't say not for not
seems like shitty language.
So did his shot you out of her
vagina. So let's just run with it. Um,
there's still time to send mom a beautiful
rose bouquet from one 800 flowers.com
because mom means so much to you.
You know she does. Without her,
you would not be here. That
is a fact. Think about that.
And for such an important occasion,
I trust one 800 flowers.com and right
now one 800 flowers.com is giving my
listeners a free, I feel like I
shouldn't call you my listeners.
That seems a bit Douchey,
almost as Douchey as saying the Joe
Rogan experience when my name is actually
Joe Rogan. So I stopped saying that
so I'm not going to say my listeners.
How about you bitches giving you bitches
a special offer on mother's Day 18
vibrant multicolored roses
and if you order them,
you will get a free glass vase for only
29 99 that's 18 vibrant multicolored
roses and a free glass vase for 29 99 and
for just 10 bucks more they'll make it
two dozen roses and a glass vase
and a delicious box of chocolates.
You can't go wrong.
That is 40% off of the regular price.
You cannot beat this amazing offer,
but it's only available today,
Tuesday,
May 6th and only while supplies last
because this shit's going to fly off the
shelf,
so hurry before it is too late.
Go to one 800 flowers.com from
your desktop or mobile device.
Click on the radio microphone in the
upper right hand corner and enter in j r e
that's one 800 flowers.com and enter j r
e or call 1-800-FLOWERS and mention j r
e we are also brought to you by ting.
Ting is a mobile company that does things
on their own terms and their own terms
is they decided to cut out all the
nonsense that's usually associated with
owning a cell phone and
having cell phone coverage.
Things like early termination fees,
things like contracts,
things like charging you for x amount
of minutes and if you get over that,
it's an overage freed.
The way Tim handles it,
it's much cleaner and in my opinion
it's, it's more, it's just more ethical.
Look, cell phone companies know
they have you by the balls.
He needed a cell phone.
Everybody does.
If you're one of those
fucking weird contrarians,
it's like I don't even own a cell
phone. Guess what? Fuck face.
You're behind the curve. That
shit's ridiculous. If you're,
it's 2014 if you don't have a cell phone,
there's something wrong with you. Okay,
it's you, you're the problem. But
if you do have a cell phone, you,
you know the pitfalls. Ting eliminates
almost all of them. First of all,
they buy time on the sprint backbone.
So what they do is they
rent sprint service. So,
and then they sell it back to you. But
they do it in a really simple, easy way.
Instead of saying you get x
amount of minutes per month,
you just pay for what you use.
If you use more, you pay more.
If you use less, you pay
less. And 98% of people,
98% would save money with Ting.
And that is clearly just because
they do mobile differently.
$440 is the average annual savings per
device for a business with 11 to 20
employees. Think about that
shit. And they have great phones.
You can bring over I phones from
sprint, iPhone four, iPhone five,
you can buy one of their
awesome android devices.
They all have the top of the line.
Android phones.
They have the Samsung Galaxy note three,
which is what I have with Tim now. I, I,
I poured my galaxy note
over to 10. Now, um,
they have the HTC one, they have, um,
all sorts of different options
and even they've gone old school.
You can buy one of those old fucking
flip phones if you're into it.
They have all kinds of
different styles and different,
different options for both. Uh, the, the,
the type of phone you have and
the, um, and the, the way you,
uh,
do you use your phone.
If you're one of those people that really
likes to use a flip phone and we were
talking about the other day,
there's a benefit and there's something
cool about being able to open it and
then shut it when the phone's off like
I'm done with you close that phone.
You don't get that by pressing
your thumb on glass. You also,
you don't get that same feeling you get
when you actually press a button to type
a number. I do miss that. There's a
benefit in that, but that's all nonsense.
You could get that anywhere.
The bottom line is what you can get with
ting is no bullshit cell phone service,
excellent coverage because they use the
sprint backbone and you can get really
good phones and you can cut out all
the nonsense where you, you don't,
you don't feel like you're
getting fucked over, you know,
and I think that's like one of the most
important things about what ting offers.
I think every cell phone service in the
future is going to have to shift over to
the, their model of pricing because
I think the idea of you, you know,
you're only getting a certain amount of
minutes and if you get over that they
charge you for it. Like that's all
stupid. Just pay for what you use.
And if you use very little, you
pay very little. And as I said,
for most people you would
save money with Ting,
98% of people that's,
that's quite a claim.
The other thing I like about ting is on
their second anniversary, for no reason,
they just decided to slash prices they
slash their prices because they got a
better offer. They decided, hey,
let's celebrate two years in business.
Let's celebrate,
uh,
an ethic that people seem to be resonating
with and let's just slashed prices.
And it's particularly
beneficial for power users.
So if you're one of those dudes,
it's on Twitter all day and downloading
videos and that kind of Shit Tengiz for
you.
So go to rogan.ting.com and save $25 off
of any of their new delicious android
devices.
That's rogan.ting.com we're
also brought to you by on it.
Oh and and I t on it is what we
call a human optimization website.
What we try to carry and sell is all
the best things that we can find.
Whether it is strength and
conditioning equipment,
whether it is foods and healthy snacks,
whether it is supplements like Alpha
brain or shroom tech sport or new mood.
We try to send you or sell you the
very best nutritional supplements,
the very best supplements
as far as protein powders,
we carry hemp force protein powder,
which is from Canada, where Nick Cutter,
Aka Craig Davidson is from
the fine land of Canada,
is allowed to grow and sell hemp to
these dullards in America that aren't
allowed to grow their own
because they're fucking goofy.
Government forbids it because,
because hemp knows marijuana.
They're like cousins.
They know each other real well.
It's fucking government doesn't trust him.
It's too close,
too close to that marijuana criminal.
Um,
you do not test positive is a big
question I get, I'd have to answer it.
I have to talk about it every time.
You do not test positive for THC,
if you by hemp,
uh,
I have to say this because the
fucking retards that run the,
uh, what is it at customs
and New Zealand's, oh my God,
you dummies.
I had a friend who ordered some
shit in New Zealand and customs.
They took and destroyed his
hemp force protein powder.
You dummies. It's probably
some thieves. The customers,
they probably stole it and they're,
they're probably making their own protein
shakes now and laugh and they're dicks
off.
But according to him,
what they said was that they confiscated
and destroyed his hemp force because
they thought it was a marijuana product.
We live in a time that
will be mocked one day,
mocked the same way we mock powdered
wigs and putting skirts over a tables the
way they used to put table leg dresses
in the olden days to keep people from
getting impure thoughts. They will
mock us, they will mock us for this,
this thing that we have with him,
but we sell it.
And if you're in America or in
a country that's not retarded,
you can buy it and you can
eat it and it's good for you.
But you should know that.
You can test positive for
some things that aren't drugs.
Like if you eat poppy seed bagels,
you will test positive for heroin.
I know it sounds crazy,
but it is true. Um,
the other things that we carry it on it,
things like warrior bar,
which is one of our new products,
which is a completely
natural buffalo meat bar,
buffalo and cranberries.
It's made by an old native American
recipe for preserving meat.
And there's no antibiotics, no
added hormones, no nitrates.
And each bar has 140 calories,
only four grams of fat, four
grams of fat, excuse me.
And 14 grams of protein per each two
ounce serving super healthy for you.
No MSG, no soy, no lactose.
And you,
you can eat these and you know,
not worry about what you're putting into
your body, not worry about, uh, you know,
sometimes you're hungry and you
want a snack. You don't want to,
you don't want to feel guilty
afterwards. Folks, eat more your bar,
not feel guilty. Set Racist.
Sound like an India now.
Anyway, go to [inaudible] Dot Com o. N N.
I t use the Codeword Rogan and save
10% off any end. All supplements.
We've got a lot of cool
shit coming at on it too.
I wish I could tell you about the latest
in the creative kettle bell series,
but it's awesome. I'll show
you Jamie afterwards, but
might have, you might have,
you might have, I'll show you
the newest version. Uh, anyway,
go to [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N N.
I t use the Codeword Rogan save 10% off
any and all supplements and a lot of
inspirational and educational
information on, on it as well.
Even if you're not into buying something,
go there and get your freak on.
All right. Nick Cutter a k Craig Davidson
is here. Cue The music. Young Jamie,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
So my pal Matt stags, he sends
me this book and he's like, dude,
you got to read this book. This book
is fucked up. You're going to love it.
Cause he knows I love Stephen
King and that, you know,
that that's sort of twisted genre.
So He sends me this book right here.
Yeah,
it's in my bag here somewhere.
Uh, he sends me Your Book and uh,
I enjoy the fucking shit out of it. I am,
I want, I want to pull it out because, um,
it's so beat up and dogeared
proves, oh, there we go.
Troop. And, uh, I guess I'm about,
what am I about 200 plus pages into
it. Um, it's really getting juicy.
I really, I'm really enjoying
it, man. Good. It's really
good. Good, good. And it's,
it's really fun and it's,
you know,
it's a long the lines of like stand by
me or one of those classic old Stephen
King Books.
You like the stand or,
or pet cemetery where it's just twisted
and dark and there's psychological shit
going on and there's horrific things
having those monsters and it's really
fucking cool man. And um,
when he sent it to me,
he told me that Nick Carter wasn't
your real name. And I was like,
well, what's, what's the deal there? Yeah.
What is, what's the deal there? Well, um,
you know, I think the most concerning
thing to me would be, is it anyone,
cause I mean, I grew up like
you, like Stephen King is
my idol. Steve, there is no,
nobody. I've read more than
Stephen King and beyond that,
like I grew up as a horror reader. I
mean I have read everything now. I see.
You mean you started diversify but I
wouldn't even say diversify cause that's
sort of like, I love the horror
genre stole like Clive Barker,
obviously Stephen King,
Peter Straub, Robert Hart.
Mccammon I mean the list goes on and
on and on that we started who I cut my
teeth on. So, um, so really
my agents said, listen,
you've been writing these things under
your own name and their kind of their,
I wouldn't even classify them as literary,
but maybe they would be a little more
to that side. Uh, rather than, than,
than the horror genre. And, um, he sort of
felt like, listen, people aren't going to,
people might be confused or,
or people might, you know,
let's have some separation basically.
And the best way to do this separation
is just to give you a new name, put this,
put this horror work.
Cause when I sent him the truth,
I mean there's no way it's anything other
than just like I wanted to write like
an eighties style hard fireball
and sort of horror novel,
like not splitting any hairs,
not trying to like make,
make it met ironic or anything.
Just trying to go straight ahead.
The horror that I grew up,
you know, loving, you know,
and try and sort of be an homage to,
to, to those writers in that time. Um,
so there's no doubt it was going to
come out as clearly a horror novel.
So he said, let's, let's just
make up a pseudonym. And I, I'm,
I wouldn't say I'm new to this, but you
know, you know, you have an agent as well.
And like, I mean, I trust my agent. I'm,
I imagine in most cases you trust
your agent. Maybe not always.
You don't trust them at all?
No.
Then we'll get to talk to me about
that type of thing. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't allow them, well I think
maybe looking back, you know,
what we did is we settled on this
pseudonym and then I quickly went,
it went away,
you know,
trying to erase any sort of sentiment
that I was ashamed of it because I think
that's, I live in Toronto and I hang
out with a lot of people in the horror,
the horror genre sort of genre writers.
And their question was like,
are you ashamed? I'm like,
fuck no. That would be the,
if that would be the worst thing for
me, for people to think that, you know,
cause I'm as proud as what I've done is
the troop is any other writing I've ever
done.
Well, so when you say literary,
like what are your other books?
I'm not familiar with
your other brother books.
Well, I wrote a book called Rustin
Bone, which is like a, a book, uh, um,
the short yeah. Short stories. Um, uh, and
then I wrote a book called the fighter,
not, not the same a fighter, the
Christian Bale movie, but, um,
and I wrote a book just
recently called Cataract City,
which is so it's sort of like, I dunno,
um, I wouldn't say chuck, he was an early
influence, but sort of like
macho, like fighting, boxing,
dogfighting, repossession, you know,
those were sort of the things really
sort of manly endeavors that they were,
I was concerned about it, interested
in with those books, but they weren't,
you know,
they certainly weren't literary like
Alice Munro or something like that.
I Dunno who else. She's a kid.
She's a Canadian, uh, you know,
a Canadian short story writer,
like a Salmon Rushdie or
you know, a Phillip Roth.
Those kind of like serious
literary writers know about
Salman Rushdie is a bunch
of Muslims. Really Mad.
Don't like that dude.
Pat Stevens was on their side and
disappointed and he was finally allowed to
stick his head up after, I don't know,
like they put a fat lie out on him. Right.
He's it as the fallow, I think. I
think the guy you who put it out died.
So I think the fat white died with
him or maybe they carried it over.
I don't really know how that works,
but he has showing up at public functions,
so I think he's less concerned
about being killed. Four guy. Yeah.
You think about like
man of all this stuff.
Could you imagine someone puts a fatwa
on you for something that you say during
the podcast are ridiculous. Yeah. I
know whoever did it and I'd kill them
first before you can just kill the
guy in the fatwa ends. That's, yeah,
you're fucked. Yeah, exactly.
They shouldn't be putting out too
many fat was because it's like,
I'm going to get you, it's
the day and age. You can't
hide behind a fatwa anymore.
No, exactly. Today's Internet, they
can find you, but I can find you too.
You could publicly expose them for
their fatwa shaming. Right. Um,
so I don't, I'm not familiar
with Salman Rushdie's work.
I've read a little bit of it and I found
it quite boring to me, honestly. Yeah,
I think, I think too, there's somewhat
with literary writing, like I had to,
I had to read it because you went
to school and did an English degree.
So I feel like there like medicine,
it's like it's not
necessarily it's good for you.
There's this sense of like you should
be reading it because it's good for you
and it'll make you a better person.
But I'm sort of, I'm past all that now.
I'd just like to read what I like to
read and if that happens to be, you know,
sort of crunchy literary fiction
where it's like dense text we'll find.
But if it's,
if it's something like a really good
horror novel or a thriller novel,
I mean I'm all over that too. As far as
I'm concerned. When it comes to fiction,
whether it's a film or
whether it's a book,
I only want to be entertained totally.
Or not illuminating. Elucidate,
enriching me with your or not. I agree.
But I went, you know, you go to school,
right? And you have too much
time on your hands, right? Yeah.
You wake up in the morning
and what do you have to do?
Maybe go to a class for two hours a day.
Um,
and so I think people in
that realm feel like they,
cause they had the time to like invest
in like really crunchy mind sort of
melting. No distinction that
really tests you but and you know,
and then they start to look down on
someone who just wants to read. Like,
like for example, I didn't mention at
all in my first one, I did a um, uh,
my English degree.
You wouldn't talk about Stephen King
because he's got these sort of looks like,
oh, him. Oh well yeah, I used to
read him when I was 12 mocked. Yeah.
He gets mocked and I was like, you know,
after awhile you're just like, wait a sec,
fuck off. You know, like
I love Stephen King.
I love a lot of writers that you
guys seem to think are, you know,
base or bullet below your esteem
and who are you in the first place?
We're just sitting in
some writing workshop.
You haven't published the Goddamn thing.
Like not to be an asshole.
I mean I like some of these people that
I'm, that I'm talking about, but like,
you know, yeah, there was,
there was that certain,
that hierarchy and unless
you're reading at this level,
but it's like most of people who like
to read have like a job that really
occupies them and they get home at night
maybe and they don't have all that much
energy. They just want to read the, you
know, for enjoyment, you know, and why,
why looked down on that. Yeah. And
anytime you're concerned about image,
so much so that you're
ignoring great works.
Like Stephen King King wrote some
really fun stuff. Absolutely. And,
and really and deeply
psychologically thrilling as well.
You can't dismiss the
stand. No, just can't or,
or it was lot.
And one thing that I noticed too,
like trying to write a horror book is
I think it's really difficult to scare
people in this day and age, right? Like
it's, it's, and so you would probably,
I don't know,
maybe you can answer this a little
bit in terms of liking in comedy.
Like I read Stephen King when I was
12 and I just read them. First of all,
he's the writer that got boys to
read of our generation, you know,
I mean there's nothing else other than
maybe choose your own adventure books
that I was reading back then until I
sort of graduated to Stephen King and um,
and so you first you read it just because
you love Stephen King. And then second,
you know,
I went back as a writer myself and you,
you sort of treat the
book is like an engine,
the movie mechanic treats and engine.
You're trying to break it down and see
what, what is working, how does this work,
how does he scare you?
And that's where you realize it's
genius because it's like, you know,
I'm working on like a model t
Ford and he's got like this,
he's working on the Delorean
engine from back to the future.
That's how much he's above, you know,
a lot of us in terms of like he is,
he works at a level I think
of like conjuring fear that
is so difficult to first
of all, see how it works. Break it down
and then try and do it yourself. Um,
and so when you have people like
looking down on him for, for that,
I just don't think they've
really interacted with his
work as closely as I have
because first of all, if you're
saying he sucks, I'm like,
I can't even touch him in some ways. And
so what are you saying about me? Well,
I just think it's one of those things
where it becomes trendy to say sucks.
Yeah.
It puts you in this sort of
elevated category of intellectual.
I think that's horseshit because fiction,
like when you start talking
about monsters or vampires,
you're automatically a fool or
you're doing foolish work. Yes. Yeah.
Whereas if you're talking about
depression and suicide and you know you're
serious, stop. I'm done with you. Right.
When it comes to like fictional movies,
especially like if someone says,
oh my God, it was an amazing
movie. I cried eyes out.
It was a horrible, not me not going to
see a piece of shit where you make me cry.
I don't want to cry. I've plenty of
opportunity to cry. You want to cry?
Watch a documentary on
Rwanda. Okay. Don't,
don't fucking cry because some fake ass
hole made some stupid movie where some
people are pretending
terrible things happening.
You're not going to learn from that.
You're just not,
I like to be elevated by my
fiction or at least thrilled. Yeah,
totally. I want to cry. No, no, I mean,
and, and I, I completely agree. Um, and,
and so, and want another thing Stephen
King does really well is his childhood.
I don't think there's another writer
to my mind really who writes about
childhood as, as well as Steven King
captures it in like a book, like itch or,
or the or, well, the movie, the body
at that became stand by me. You know,
he captures that time in a, in a
boy's life, especially that, um,
it's just remarkable. You know what I
mean? And, and uh, so, so I think now too,
I know Patton Oswald did like a, I
think it was, I forget where he did it,
but he did like a long article based on
his admiration really for Stephen King.
So I think now there's a
renaissance, finally, Stephen King.
It's got to be close to 70 now where
people are finding like, okay, this guy's,
this guy's pretty good. Well, again,
it's just one of those things people
love calling someone out or they love
shaming someone. They love
diminishing someone's work. They just,
they just enjoy it. Especially
if it elevates them. Yes.
Yeah. Or it's like a hipstery thing. It's
like, well, too many people like this,
it can't be good. Um, because
too many people like it,
and I have to like these sort of offbeat,
well,
haven't you read the offbeat
Peruvian poet? No, I haven't. I mean,
I'm sure he or she is awesome. Maybe,
but maybe not. Maybe not exactly.
Someone tried to turn you onto a band
that till they tell you it's amazing and
it's shit.
Yeah.
You got to go down to like a basement
somewhere and they'll be playing to like
five people or does this give you,
they send you all the time.
People send me like a youtube clip
and it's dog eat dog shit music.
And they were like, this is amazing.
This band, there's so nuanced. Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
And if you don't end sort of like if
you don't get it then you're out. Yeah.
I guess that's sort of like your
lapse in judgment or ability to really
recognize how good this is and
that's what separates them from you.
It's not complex enough. That's
right. Yeah. Yeah. That's right.
Craig. I am lacking in some,
some serious way. You know,
I'm Stephen King.
It's a,
it's an interesting comparison that
you said that Stephen King captures
childhood really well cause I think that's
something you did really well in this
book is as as well. Thank
you. You captured this uh,
sort of lord of the flies type scenario.
I don't want to give away
too much of the script. Sure.
But when things go awry in the,
in the beginning you sort of see this
social hierarchy that's going on and you
see shifts in the social hierarchy
based on the events that take place.
And it's, it's quite fascinating. Um,
I really wish that you did it under
your own name and I hope like Richard
Bachmann,
Bachmann cry. Why didn't Steven
King do that? Go with Bachman.
Why he did it is because
he was too prolific.
Is that what his agent just
said? Listen man, first of all,
like I don't get it man,
cause he's probably got,
cause he's still to this day,
he's still pumping out books
at an enormous rate and
big like slobber knocking
books. He's not, you
know, little tiny. Uh,
so I think he probably
writes like me on a good day,
I can write like maybe 3000 words.
That's if like the pistons are firing
really well and I try and write a thousand
words every day. You know,
that's sort of my, my limit.
But he must write like 5,000 words
a day consistently. And it's strong,
strong stuff. So, so that was why Bachman
came to be, because his agent was like,
listen, we just can't be flooding the
market. We Stephen King, we got to,
let's separate you out.
Let's just put some of these stuff out
under a different name. And then you know,
you still have your book out every year,
which is still on an astronomical rate.
So, yeah, it was just for him.
It was a totally a sense of,
he just had too much to say.
Wow. Yeah. That's amazing.
And he eventually took those Bachman books
and put them under Stephen King. Yeah.
Yeah. It became like an open secret
really. You know, and you're right.
Then he republished them under
under his own name basically was um,
what was the movie that they did where
it was the dark half Bachman book?
I'm not sure,
but it was based on really,
it was based at Richard Stark
or George Stark was his,
his pseudonym and that that's when it's
student and started started stocking.
Right. Yeah. Yeah.
That was definitely based
on his experience having
written under a pseudonym. Um,
I, that might've been a
Bachman book. Um, but the,
there was another example
of his, his, you know,
ability to sort of not just be so prolific
but also be prolific under like some
really established territory
with its forced his work.
He was always a writer.
Yes.
How many times did he do a book about
a writer character? Yeah. Yeah. I know.
I think it's because the narrative is
easier to write from that perspective.
You know, even the voice that you
find, I think it's like I'm a writer,
this voices,
because I was reading,
rereading the body lately made
into stand by me and that's again,
that's a writer character who's
writing that. And um, you're right,
he does have a lot of writer characters,
which is something I've avoided
up to this point. But you know,
looking at the success, what's that? A
lot of writers in Maine, what's all, yeah,
you're right. It's almost
all set in Maine. He started
staked out that territory.
Absolutely. As have you ever
been to Maine? I've never,
I used to live in New Brunswick,
which is right sort of right above main,
but I never crossed the border
and went down into Stephen King,
terrorized stupid. I should have,
there's some beautiful parts of Maine,
but the there I don't want,
I want to be kind if I can.
There's some of the dumbest
human beings on the phone
saying they'll take disrespect at that.
If I was being unkind,
I would call them a bunch of kid
fucking Weirdos that live in the woods.
Um, not all of them. And there's
those great parts of Maine.
Bangor is a great city.
Yeah. Uh, the,
the real problem with Maine is there's
some areas where there's nothing.
Like there's an area between
Portland, Maine, and Bangor.
When you're driving up from Boston where
you go at least an hour without seeing
anything driving 70 miles an hour
and no radio, there's nothing. Oh,
you can't even catch a station,
won't get anything that is just sled.
You hit scan and you're
fucking radio starts smoking.
It just keeps going. There's nothing,
I mean, I don't know how it is now.
There's no radio, there's
no gas stations, man.
There's just a straight shot of like
70 miles of just, I've just dairy road,
pine trees or whenever. If you run out
of gas, you're fucked. Ceville oh man.
And if it's snowing out,
you're really fucked. Yeah.
We used to do that drive all the time
cause we do gigs up in Bangor. Oh, okay.
If you made fun of Maine, even
at all. I mean even slightly,
the pitchforks are coming
up and scream at you.
You call them maniacs if you
called the maniacs. Correct.
Get up and get fucking Naheed mangy they,
they love it.
They love it up there.
It's beautiful.
It's absolutely beautiful country and
you know they have everything up there.
Deer and Moose.
Yeah. It's like great that way start
if you want to get back to nature,
I feel like that's probably
the place you might start.
You want to be a survivalist.
Yeah.
Main might be a place to
get your crew started.
It's probably one of the least
populated states in the union. Yeah,
it's way it's way out there, you know, for
us to New Brunswick is pretty, you know,
you're well east at that point.
But what's odd is Montreal is north.
Yes.
Main yet completely
cosmopolitan. Yeah. Very,
very modern in every respect.
The people are fantastic and edgy.
Been up there for you, I guess for
MMA events and comedy events as well.
Both for both.
Oh,
I'm going to Montreal since the early
nineties probably since 1990 itself.
Cause when I first started going
up there, I love mine. I do too.
We've never had an opportunity to, to
live there. I've lived, oh well you know,
well across the country, but of course
there's the Francophone influence there,
which I don't, I don't know. I guess
you going up there as an American,
I don't know how much interaction you
have with that necessarily, you know?
Do you really? Yeah, well of
course. Yeah. I mean a lot of,
a lot of great MMA fighters are,
are,
are at least a couple of frank
phoned GSP and Patrick Coty and Lazo.
David was Ocj with Wazo
classes. Carmel. There's um,
yeah that holds five.
The,
the Tristar Gym from Montreal is one
of the best MMA gyms in the world,
which I don't know how to happen,
you know,
cause MMA like I used to live in Calgary
and that's actually another odd MMA
hotbed. There's, there's a
lot, there's a lot of interest.
I don't know if there's a lot of great
fighters yet who have come out of Calgary,
but there's a quite a few are there now.
Good fighters.
Very good fighters coming up and yeah,
and I did a magazine article on,
on one guy who, um, uh, you know, who won.
I just followed him to his first
professional fight actually,
which was an interesting
sort of thing to follow any,
actually he hurt himself really
badly in that fight and that was it.
That was his career.
Um,
but, but I know the gym that he was
working out of had, it was a real,
I mean it was, I've, I've rarely been
and felt that level of like comradery,
but also competition. I'm sort
of in such a tight, small area,
so, so, um, that's what you build
great fighters that pressure.
Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. Yeah. I don't know
what it is about Canada and producing, uh,
mixed martial arts fighters,
but also mixed martial arts fans.
There's more MMA fans per capita in Canada
than anywhere. Yeah. You bloat the, uh,
the Toronto, what is it? The Air Canada
Center. We sell that place out, I think,
and they sold out the Roger Center
at the Roger Center. Gigantic,
huge place that used to be. He used to
have a different name. Right. What was it?
Skydome skydome. Yeah, exactly. So
that's, and that's amazing. 60,000,
60,000 to why it was GSP fight I
think versus just Jake shields.
Oh, that's right. That's
right. Yeah, we are,
we're a great sporting supporting nation.
You know,
we just had the raptors just
got bounced out of the playoffs,
like the basketball team and uh,
you know,
selling out and then they had like people
like 20,000 fans clustered outside of
the arena watching. So that's amazing.
Yeah, it is. It's a great, it's,
and it's great that you guys in
the UFC come up and I think the,
I think for a while there,
it was mostly you guys were down in
Las Vegas and a few other places,
but then you decided to
come up to Canada and it's,
but it's been good for you guys.
Been great for us too.
We'll Canada of just has a love of all
things manly. Yes, we do have that,
I think. Yeah. They're
not tracking by it. No.
Whereas there's a lot of embarrassment
in America. Things manly.
Yeah. Push it away or like, oh,
that's a little too testosterone.
He kind of a thing. Yeah. I have a
friend who was talking about, um, a,
a sitcom that he was working on
and he was, uh, talking about, um,
there's a woman that was, uh, one
of the leads that was trying to, uh,
introduce you is also one of the writers
and she was trying to introduce these
male characters.
There were like the type of guys that
she likes and they were like, oh,
he's two to two jockeys.
Too much of a meathead.
Like they didn't want anybody who was
interested in other women other than the
girl that they're with.
They didn't want that dilemma.
They didn't want anyone who was dominant
over the woman in the relationship.
They didn't want anybody who
was obsessed with her body.
You're working out were like,
those are like all of our boat and we just
can't go. You can't have those things.
And it was the writers themselves
because they felt threatened by that,
those types of men.
So they were rejecting those characters.
Girls don't like that. Those
guys, there's a Turkey, you know,
guys who wear scarves and stuff.
She was getting angry. She was like,
what do you see these, this
is what I like. Like yeah,
me because the type of guys I like,
women don't like these guys. Like what?
And whether you like him or not,
that's, that's kind of like a,
that's an element of our society to like
why purposely sort of ignore them and
oh no, that wouldn't screen test whether
we don't, we don't want say embarrassing.
Well I think I was thinking too
about before coming here, like you,
your career has sort of had,
I think you must have run up against
that a lot because like I remember when
fear factor came out, there
was a sense, you know,
there were these hyperbolic newspaper
articles like, ah, society is collapsing.
You know, it's fear factor. Like
we're, you know what I mean?
People are doing things that like,
why are we getting people to eat bugs or
stuff? And I thought, I love that show.
You know what I mean?
And then the UFC comes along and
it's the same kind of like Ha,
what was one of your politicians had the,
the human cockfight.
A bunch of them use that,
right? Yeah. And so you've been,
you've been situated a along that
that line I think and so you'd be,
I'd be sensitized to it if I were you. At
this point it's like, come on, screw off.
Well,
if I was
doing things from a public
relations standpoint,
I've been nothing but poor choices.
Right. You looked at it that way. Yeah.
When I was first starting to work for
the UFC was in 1997 and the people that
was, I wasn't on sitcoms on Newsradio
the sitcoms. That's right. Yeah.
People were talking to me like I
was doing porn. Like they're like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Like that.
Like they thought it ruin your career
really. You're involved in cage fighting.
Like what's wrong? I was like, it's just,
it's martial arts they take
that takes place in a cage.
It could take place in a high school
gymnasium. Would that be okay with you?
Would that make it more sanitized for you
as in a field? Would that be all right,
frank? What difference does it make where
it takes place in martial arts, but the,
um, the rejection of things manly. I mean,
it has its roots in some pretty
disgusting behavior. You know,
when you see like the Steubenville rape
case and sure the jocks conspired as
long, uh, along with people that worked
at the school to high sort of, yeah,
cover that shit up,
that kind of, you know,
misogynistic, supported
thinking. The group think of,
you know, fuck these bitches, you
know? Yeah. All the men together.
But those are just weak humans.
Those are pathetic humans.
It has nothing to do with masculinity.
Yeah, no, I completely agree.
But that's the thing.
It was like masculinity gets tied into
all the reprehensible aspects of male
behavior against women, not just a
celebration of things that men love.
Men love certain things that
don't harm other people.
Like men love cars that are
loud and fast. Yes. You know,
men love a lot of thing.
Men love shooting guns.
Doesn't mean they want to kill people.
No.
It's like there's something
fun about shooting a gun.
And if you bring that up and you say that,
oh, I don't have gun, I don't own guns,
that's not leaving. They need to
take away all the guns. I mean,
I've had these conversations with people
whenever there's a school shooting,
they need to take away all the guns.
Maybe they need to stop giving people
these fucking drugs that make them
psychotic. You ever think about
the dragon, the over it? Yeah.
That's sort of the over
medication of some of these kids.
And 90% of all school shooters,
90 plus are either on Ssri or
eyes or are recovering from ssrs.
They're in withdrawal
from antidepressants.
And it doesn't necessarily mean that
the antidepressants caused that.
But I do believe there's,
without a doubt and over prescription of,
without a doubt,
he go to a doctor.
The doctor's not going to
look at a holistic approach
to your life and say, hey,
you know, maybe you were raised
by shitty human beings. Yeah.
Maybe you need counseling for a decade
Beta blocker and that'll
all the bad thoughts
walled off. Yeah. And we'll not only that,
all your inhibitions are going to be less,
and your ability to understand the
consequences of your actions will be less
into your ability to be depressed and
to feel terrible about bad actions has
also been removed.
There's a lot of things that happen
when you put people on drugs that change
your neurochemistry. It doesn't mean
that those drugs are bad. You know,
I get these fucking tweets from these
people that can understand a complex
argument or a nuanced conversation.
I have friends personally
that have benefited greatly
from antidepressants. Yeah,
and I don't I, it's not that I
deny them or don't support them.
I think there's definitely
a place for them,
but I think when you look at all these
people that have killed mass groups of
people and you find this
one common denominator over
and over and over again to
ignore that, but concentrate entirely
on the tool itself is ridiculous.
Most human beings are absolutely incapable
of walking into a school and shooting
a bunch of children.
Most human beings.
What is it about some human beings
that are capable? I don't know,
but that's not being discussed.
Gun Control's being discussed,
the raising of children's
not being discussed,
it's gun control that's being discussed.
I find that ridiculous. I really do.
And I think that that it sort of
gets lumped in with this rejection of
manliness, this, you know, this, uh,
support of anything that's anti male or
this denial of these base male instincts
yeah. Don't necessarily have to be
harmful to other people like competition.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, there's
so much about it. I mean, I'm,
my career is in a way, uh,
you know, again, my early stuff was
all about my boat men doing men things,
which some of it is, is
silly and self harming, but,
but also it's like something that I
think built into our genome we need to
express in, in a certain way.
You know what I mean? So,
but I know that a certain segment of,
of readers or who just were like,
they were turned off and immediately in
the same way that and the same way that
these TV writers were just like,
no,
but that's just the wrong people for
your stuff. That's all new defined.
You know what you need to find a
receptive audience. And the same,
I think your career has been a lot of
that is about finding the right. Uh, and,
and also I think also for both of us,
it's about making people realize
that like, I'm not a meathead,
you're not a meathead. Do you know
what I mean? There's, but the,
I feel like people think that like I'm,
they read this book and
they assume that I'm,
I am a meathead or am I wrote a book
called the fighter's. Yeah. Yeah.
And so your boxing match, right,
right. And would be the same. Same,
I don't mean to put words in your mouth,
but I don't know if you've had the same
experiences yourself and it's sort of
like, um, you know, I wasn't
raised that way. I don't,
I don't myself a typical
and whatever. If you're a jock, that's
fine. You know what I mean? Not, you know,
you're a Steubenville Ville type,
you know,
if you have that kind of job mentality,
it's not the,
I wouldn't say that it's like a, what
would you call that? I'd say it Bro,
but I don't think so. I think
grows are more lights, rapist.
It's straight up a rapist.
He's a shit human being and most likely
you have a bad relationship with your
mother or your sisters or someone in your
family who just did a terrible job of
expressing to you the responsibility of
being the physically stronger sex and
the the one that is the penetrator,
not the penetrate. Yeah. You know,
this whole relationship
between men and women.
I think a huge part of
it is how they're raised,
how human beings are raised and what
kind of relationship where they have with
their family. I had a really
good relationship with my mother.
I'm really lucky in that respect. Like
I've never had any hate towards women,
but I have friends that genuinely
don't, women like women, I mean,
and that came from their, from their
upbringing. Either because their father,
maybe they had to divorce or something
is bad. It's like she's awful bad.
Moms are bad moms started out bad mom's
bad relationships with women and they
just, they just don't like
women. I mean, I don't do,
I don't have good friends
that are like that,
but I know people that will say
fucking cons. They're all the same.
They'll say shit like that around
you and you're like, come on,
you're missing out.
This is a lot of great chicks out there.
Just like there's a lot of dudes
that I would, I would, if I,
there's some people that if I
was alone with them in the woods,
I would seriously think about killing
them right away with it. Yeah. Yeah.
If you are ready. Yeah. If you
around, here's the perfect example.
If you are around that
fucking not Joe Paterno,
who was the other guy that got
raped? Oh, Sandusky. I wasn't around.
If I was in the woods and it was just
me and sent dusk and there's sort of a
grave,
maybe just sit and there's no one around
and I looked to the left and there's
just miles and miles of woods.
Fuck you. I kill that guy.
Yeah.
If I knew he raped kids 100% I'd
kill him if I could get away with it.
Why? Because I don't believe that
all lives are created equal. I don't,
I think that there's, there's a yin and a
Yang to the world. There's good and bad.
There's positive and negative. There's
give and take and you got to trim weeds,
right? You gotta, you gotta shoot
dogs that have rabies. You know,
there's a lot of things that happen in
this world that are uncomfortable that
people don't like. Their unfortunate
but that they need to be done.
And when you find some guy
likes to rape children,
you should remove him from the
earth. Yeah, yeah. This is a mess.
You can't clean this up.
No,
and I feel like it's high to know that
I'm probably getting out of my depth here
in terms of what my real understanding
of it, but I feel like it's such a built,
like it's something deep in
your Dna Helix and your genome.
Like you're not going to route it out.
You know what I mean?
The best you can do is hope that you
don't or aren't in a situation or you're,
you're, you're somehow away from
the source of what you're, you're,
you know, issue is basically, but I
mean, if you're out in society, I mean,
of course you're going
to be sort of up against,
and I don't think you get
cured from something like
that. I mean, I don't, I again,
I don't know for sure, but
I feel like, yeah, yeah. I,
well I think there may be a time in the
future where we can understand and get
to the root of these behaviors
and perhaps access whatever it is,
is wrong in a person's mind that makes
them either have a desire to victimize
children or have the ability to victimize
children and not feel remorse for it
or be attracted to it.
Do you as a writer, um,
do you,
cause I was a comic.
I watch a lot of things that I don't agree
with and I will be no other comedians
doing things or just,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
Like a watch religious
programs. Okay. Yeah.
I watch a conservative right
wing propaganda shows and
just be seeding and every
muscle tense when you're
watching it sometimes, oh no,
just try to get empty when I do those
things because I don't want to get angry.
Um,
I,
what I want to do is try to find the
patterns in their thinking and trying and
you see a lot of commonality in,
in these sort of group think mindset's
whether it's Republicans or I see it in
feminists a lot. I see it in
male feminists, I see it in, um,
there's people like they,
they choose sides and then
there's a massive amount of
confirmation bias and you
see it, you know, you see it
both ways. But as a writer,
do you like to study like certain
mindsets or certain people that are just
completely alien to your way of thinking
to try to grab pieces of the way they
interact to jump into their head and
said you could trace a narrative thread
through their eyes? I have tried that,
I think. I think that's, you know,
I know writers and I certainly
know Comedians who, I mean
it's sort of like the,
the, the, the rage based comedian.
Like you really want to sort of
confront these things, you know,
and like really go on a good harangue.
I'm it. And I think, I think, uh,
really it's sometimes not even
funny with a, with a comedian,
but it's really true and it's
really like honest and it's really,
you're actually getting more of a social
commentary at that point. Like Hicks.
Yeah, exactly. Like you're
getting a really strong
distilled, powerful medicine,
you know. Um, and there's some writers
who sort of work in the satirists domain,
I guess, who started do the same thing,
you know, over the length of a book. Um,
so I've tried that.
I've never found as much success with it,
at least not yet, you know? Um,
cause the same thing. Of course I uh,
we have a strong conservative,
you know, base, you know,
conservative radio always gets,
gets on my nerves.
It's funny cause we have Right now we
have rob Ford are our mayor and Toronto
who's doing all sorts of hilarious
because he is in Rehab now. Uh, you know,
and he's like, he's no
end of fun. You know,
I was sitting at the bar yesterday when
I got in and I was talking to somebody,
he's act at a defense contractor
actually. And he was like, he, you know,
he sounds like he seems
like a pretty good guy.
At least he's straight out
honest. I'm like, he is a,
he was a guy you could probably go
out and feel like you'd have a beer
with and I don't think he looked
down at you for sure. But, um,
he's also the mayor of our city and he's,
he's,
I mean he's a bit of a goof and he's
a bit of a bully I find as well.
But it's funny to listen
to the conservative pundits
cause they've got to turn
themselves into paroxysms and back
twist to try and defend his behavior
basically.
And it gets more and more difficult to
kind of defend the behavior of a man who
keeps doing more.
And more interesting kind of
a WHO's trying to defend him.
Wow. Really? Once you've planted
your well, conservatives,
I feel like I am more liberal,
so quite liberal. Uh, so once,
I think once a conservative or liberal,
but once you plant your stick in the dirt,
you just gotta keep,
you gotta keep holding onto that stick
even though the wind is blowing you like
straight back. Yeah. And one of the, one
of them was like, well, I mean, you know,
he's getting,
he's getting videotaped all the time by,
you think he'd be hanging around,
you know,
I can't believe his
friends are videotaping.
It's like he's hanging
around with drug dealers.
You can't really expect a drug dealer
not to do something that may or may not
profit them in some way. So anyways,
but you know, and of course,
you know the one talking head says that
another one. Yeah, that's, that's true.
I never looked at it that way.
So then suddenly that becomes an arguable
point that they can be like, yeah,
he's getting victimized again.
That was the argument about Donald
Sterling. Oh God. Y'All know his clippers.
Yellow's the argument like,
Hey,
the guy's getting illegally wire tapped.
You know,
we'll give him a give him a up.
Yes, that's right. He didn't know. He's
just an old doddering old man, which yeah,
true enough.
I feel,
I heard some argument that he was actually
asking her to tape him because yes,
he felt like his head was going to
tapioca and he couldn't remember anything
anymore. So he's like, please take me.
So that I remember all the things that
I say apparently that's the truth. Yeah.
That was actually part of her job
wire tapped himself basically.
Yeah.
And her job was to tape their conversation
so that he would remember what they
talked about.
So like there were certain issues that
he had to clear up and certain things
that he had to do.
She was apparently employed by him
in some sort of a Pr Sassy. Yeah.
Yeah.
So it's funny because even discussing it
like w d like what does this guy have a
right to privacy? People were like, I
can't believe you're supporting him.
Like there's so many fucking morons out
there that have the ability to comment
on anything that gets discussed.
Like you can't think of the guy's
thinking is reprehensible, but yet think,
hey, why is this? Is it,
why is it okay to just listened
to a private conversation
that this guy's having
because somebody recorded it and then
find him for that private conversation.
I don't think it is.
I don't think it's,
you're right. I mean, I'm, I,
these are one of, you know,
you've heard this a lot of times and of
course you have to separate what he said
and the reprehensible,
clearly the longstanding,
reprehensible nature of this
man has, he's, you know,
sort of proven to be over like 20 year
span. And then of course the question is,
and it's been asked already,
why,
why is he still in that position
where everyone knows he was, uh,
a racist dirt bag, but no one was,
you know, doing anything about it.
And I think at this point they got, the
players basically pushed it. They said,
listen, if you don't get rid
of this guy, we not come out
and play anymore.
And apparently it got to that point,
he also represents a very unsavory aspect
of our culture. Yeah, that's right.
So it's important to take a stand
and say, hey, this guy's got to go.
What I didn't get,
the thing that puzzled me the most is
that they find them two point $5 billion
for a conversation that
he had in his house.
Like I don't see that standing
up in court. And he is,
he's a litigious dude,
so he's going to sue the fuck out of that.
They're going to lose so much money.
They're going to lose millions of dollars
because they tried to find him two
point $5 million to make a point. They're
going to lose so much money. And I had,
I wondered a conversation too,
you know,
because now the value of that team
is up in the air. Like what does it,
what does it work? You know? And I think,
I think it's going to be
worth more because once they,
if they make them sell it,
you know what I mean? Because then it's
almost like Tabula Rasa, we can redo it.
It's like we're getting rid of this
old troglodyte and you know, who knows.
It might be like black ownership who
comes in? Magic Johnson, Magic Johnson.
I think Oprah Winfrey was
sort of in chosen. She was,
that was all just nonsense.
Okay. Um, but yeah, magic
Johnson would be the,
cause he was one of the ones who was
actually insulted deeply. Plus he has HIV.
It's even better. Right? He's got
everything's good. He loves Jesus.
Get them in there and x Laker. Yeah, he's
perfect. He's great basketball player.
And he was one of the ones that I think
she was a in trouble for taking photos
with. That's right. That's, and that's
what sterling brought it up. He was like,
do we really have to have you
taking pictures with Magic Johnson?
Dumb. But it's an interesting, you
know, it's, it is, it is an end.
It's amazing how quick it blew up to me.
Like I just saw it on some
website and I thought, well,
there's just an old dumb white guy
saying old dumb white guy things.
But it was much more clearly,
much bigger than that.
Well if it was something else,
like say if he was safe,
he was a president of a company,
a big company,
General Electric or something like that.
And he had a little piece on
the side and he was like, Hey,
stop taking pictures of black eyes.
It wouldn't get nearly the response as
someone who has benefited tremendously
from black athletes. Right. That's right.
The amount of money that that guy has
made because directly because of the work
of black athletes,
it's got that whole slave owner type
quality to it. You know? And there were,
there were rumors that, you know,
back in a couple of years ago,
he'd gone into the dressing
room and all the, you know,
basketball players had been in various
stages of undress. And he's like,
I like seeing all this, you know, black,
black flesh, you know what I mean?
Sort of a thing. So he said to
a woman, he brought a woman, oh,
is that how a locker room?
And he was saying,
look at all these beautiful black box.
Right. That's the exact quote. Yeah, yeah.
Who knows?
Yeah.
I think things like that are going to
spiral and all sorts of direction and you
can, you can quote things that may,
he may or may not actually say,
but I mean the guy does,
you know,
at a certain point it's like you've
opened Pandora's box, my friend.
Well he didn't even mean to
no so dumb and old, right?
Can't remember shit. No. So Pandora's
box sorta opened the belt on its own.
That's right.
Do you think though that as a writer
for like studying a guys like that,
do you actively do that?
Do you actively like watch how a guy
thinks he sort of absorb his stupid
thinking? I certainly find, I've
done it more in magazine articles.
I've wrote like profiles, you know, of of
people. But I've used that to move into,
into my fictional work too. So like, um,
you like if it was a basketball player,
say that you were falling around,
you would try to climb into their mind,
shadow them. Really like you physically
shadow them and what does your day, can I,
can I follow you?
And of course that's up to the level
of how much they're willing to have you
basically dug their heels
for as long as they're there.
But I mean the more you can do that,
the better it's the better the actual
article is going to be depending on if
they want that or not. But like the, um,
the MMA fighter I followed obviously
he was just an amateur guys.
His name was Ryan styles. Uh, and,
and he actually only had one
fight and was up in red deer.
So like Calgary and then red here's
about two or three hours away.
And it was like in a, a civic center sort
of a thing. And uh, but he was really,
his father is great story,
man.
I find the best stories sometimes
are where you don't quite make it,
you know what I mean?
Like athletically,
it's like you put your heart and your
guts and your soul into it and you're just
not quite good enough. Right. You know
what I mean? There's something about you,
you just can't quite get over the hump.
You know,
I think I find those are the stories
that are the most hit my heart,
the strongest, you know, and his
father is on the Calgary Swat team now,
but he was, uh, had pat
played forever in the,
in the junior league of hockey and he
made it up for a cup of coffee with the
leafs for like two games,
but he played professional hockey for
two games and his son was like an an
incredible wrestler,
sort of had, you know,
had the classic sort of MMA
pedigree and uh, but he drove a, uh,
like a sandwich truck.
Do you know those things?
They go around to work sites and you
know, a, I like a catering truck.
And so I followed him for like three or
four days on that job and he actually
said that he let people take
things on credit, you know,
and so people would
build up like a hundred,
couple hundred bucks before they
paid it off. Finally. And one guy,
I guess like just, you know, we went
to a Kim mechanic shop and he was like,
it's so and so here. It needs to settle
as bill. He's like, no, he went up,
he's like a wildcat are now up in
Fort Mcmurray, like 10 hours away.
He just bailed. He just left in the
middle of the night. So Tony, you know,
who has a, has a, had a wife
and a young kid got in the car,
I went up and found them and uh, and, and
got his money back, you know, so I mean,
this is the sort of mentality
that this guy had. So,
so when I think I got a pretty strong
story out of that just by being able to
stay with them long enough, he was
really nice to speak to me, talked to me,
and you got in borrowed
inside of his head. Um,
and I think the strongest work
comes from as close as you can,
can get to those people, you know? Yeah.
Isn't it fascinating
that we have this deep,
deep connection to towards people that
really are never going to realize their
goals. It's a painful, I feel the
same way myself. You know what I mean?
It's like I've always felt
like the mountain goes up
and up and up. You got to,
if you're going to hit your point on
it at some point and you gotta be happy
with that spot where you are
in the mountain, whenever you,
whenever you reached that spot.
I think that's the biggest part in life
really is just accepting your spot on
the mountain wherever it happens,
be well.
It's also the,
the real issue with putting all of your
eggs in one basket and that basket being
athletics and especially athletics,
especially combat athletics,
the idea that you're going to have some
sort of a long and successful fruitful
career by throwing your bones and another
person trying to separate themselves
from their consciousness.
That's quite ridiculous because just the
very act of doing it in preparing for
that very active to the amount of damage
that your body and your brain even
endures is. But we have this
idea in our heads that, you know,
a guy has to be an undefeated
champion and then, you know,
my son's going to be a champion some
day. Like, man, if you're really lucky,
your son won't be a champion.
If you're really lucky,
your son will learn the valuable
lessons of martial arts as far as like
character development and the,
as far as your ability to overcome what
seemed to be unsurmountable obstacles.
But to become a champion,
you have to be a crazy person.
You have to be crazy person who's obsessed
with nothing but that and that will
take over your life.
Yeah.
And I feel like having worked Avi
obviously with people like that, you know,
shadowed them and recognizing
that mindset. Um, uh, I,
you know,
and I find too,
like there's just some point at which
like there's some gifts that are just
bestowed by genetics or something,
and it doesn't matter how hard you work,
you're not going to quite get to that.
Maybe that level that separates the real,
and you won't know that until you hit it.
You know what I mean?
You're not going to know that
wall until you run into it.
And I feel like for some people,
like I was talking to one guy,
just a guy at the gym and,
and uh,
he said something more or
less like the best that he,
he ever felt in a fight was when he was
up against someone he knew was better
than him and he knew he was going to lose.
And if they fought a hundred times,
he'd lose a hundred times.
But he tacked guy,
he made that guy see
something about himself.
He got that close to him that the other
guys sort of recognize I'm a frail,
I made out of the same crumbling stuff
that he's made out of. And so, you know,
sort of pierce that Teflon armor that,
that I think some fighters carry around
with themselves and he's like, that's,
that's all I could do. That for
me is the victory. I still lost.
But I made that guide,
discover something about himself that
he hadn't discovered up until that point
because he'd never been tested
to the point that I got to.
I wasn't able to test them. And I thought
that's another part about just being,
recognizing what you're able to do. You
know, and it may not be beating them,
but it's you,
you find some other measure of success.
That's fascinating because to me,
if you say that someone can get so close,
they could test someone,
that means that they could beat him.
They just have to figure out what it is
they did wrong and going out again and
work harder. That's where the madness
lies. Yeah. Maybe that's it, isn't it?
The madness lies in the preparation.
The madness in the trying
to like what separates a champion
from someone who was just very good.
Well, from my personal experience
involved in martial arts competition,
there's a level that some people are
just not willing to push themselves.
Is that it really? Yeah, it's a big
part of it. And then outside of that,
there the other variables or genetics.
Psychology,
some people have,
some people have a different psychology.
What's really interesting is
people that have been bullied, um,
and especially people that
have larger brothers that,
that bullied them in the
house their whole life.
Those are the scariest
fuckers on the Braille.
It's like GSP I think was
bullied and he was now. But yeah,
he Weidman was bullied. Jon Jones has
a good relationship with his brothers,
but he has a giant brother
who was way bigger than him.
His brother Arthur is a beast.
He's a pro football player and he fucks
John up all the time whenever the rest
of today still fuck. Yeah,
he's huge. So because of that,
I think that John grew up with this
just super athlete brother and he ain't
afraid of shit. It doesn't
seem like it. Yeah. Cause
fucking brother's a month. Any,
he was sort of what an imprinted them
at such a young age too, you know.
I mean I think that's it too.
You get these things impressed on your
flesh at a young age and you don't forget
those lessons. Yeah. Brothers
are a big one, man. It's
usually, for whatever reason,
the younger brother, that's the real beast
because the younger brother and doors,
the beatings at the older brother gives
him and because of that it develops this
sorta steely determination. It's quite
frightening. I could totally see that.
That's totally makes sense.
Both on a physical level,
but on an emotional kind of,
um,
you know,
you're getting that adamantium kind of
mindset about things and just got to keep
prevailing. I've always thought to like,
because I do watch a lot of MMA and,
and I, I love it both as a
sport and boxing as well,
but also like the psychological aspect
of it really fascinates me and I've,
I've always felt like how
painful it must be to come up.
I always think about like Michael
Jordan and who were, you know,
we would think differently
of Dominique Wilson,
w Wilkins if Michael Jordan ever existed.
And I think we think differently of so
many fighters if GSP hadn't existed or,
or Silva or, you know, Jon Jones, these
sort of long reining sort of champions.
Um, and, uh, and, and I, I, you would
know better having been been through it,
but there's, you know what I mean?
There's that next level who can't quite,
you know, they have their one
shot, they can't quite clear it.
And some are lucky to have another op
opportunity at as sort of Gulf go back at
it and can still make a good career
for themselves. But I find that MMA,
especially in the UFC right now,
is there's some long reigning
champions and the peep,
and that's what people love.
You know, they sort of love,
but all the focus is on them.
And then these people think the guys
underneath who could be awesome,
where it not for, for a GSP. That's
the whole purpose. I knew champion.
That's right. Dominant other
over other savages. Yeah,
that's,
that's the thing about the being the
second best guy who could have been a
champion in any other era. That's gotta
be so mad. I wouldn't it be, yeah.
A junior dos Santos is a good example of
that. People always compare jr junior,
junior dos Santos was the champion.
He knocked out Cain Velasquez. Right?
But it was at a time where
Cain Velasquez was injured.
He tore a ligament in his knee.
His knee was all fucked up.
He didn't have good mobility and
junior caught him with a big punch.
Then they fought two more
times and Cain destroy them.
Freedom from pillar to post probably
took years off of his life with those
beatings. I had friends who were martial
artists and fighters and you know,
either former pro fighters are guys have
been involved in fighting their whole
life. Who universally texted me
and emailed me and said, dude,
that fight took years off that guy's life.
They could,
they just felt it even watching,
especially the second one, the, the, the,
the, the uh, the third one rather than
the last one. The um, the second rematch,
just unbelievable. Beating
the Canaan. Canaan,
he doesn't knock you out.
He just malls you and,
and really just reduces you in some
terrible way. Well, he keeps a pace.
It's almost inhuman for a heavyweight
and heavyweight for 240 pound man to keep
up with him. Good fucking luck.
It's probably not going to happen.
And a lot of that's genetic. Like I
talked to Bob Cook, who's his trainer.
He said that guy could go a couple of
months outside of training, get injured,
be out for a couple months,
then come back in and out work.
Everybody just doesn't get
out of shape and you, wow.
Mexicans are kind of known for that.
There's some tough fight boxers too.
Like it's a, it's a, it seems like
a tough culture. Fuck Mexicans.
I think some of the grittiest
toughest fighters of all time.
I totally MMA or boxing the N in
during endurance to their stamina.
It's just shocking and they just, they
don't stop. They don't, you're right.
They're sorta just like, you're going to
have to hit me with a house like Julio,
Cesar Chavez. You remember when that
guy has to fight? He would just ding.
The Bell had rung ring and
he just start moving forward,
throwing a barrage of punches that
will never end until you drop.
And he fought like didn't he have an
enormous record in terms of like I thought
like a hundred fights or something and
more than that he had 197 fights before
he ever suffered a loss. Yeah, that's,
that's how it was. [inaudible] 97 and Oh,
you ever saw for careers of
some other fighters, you know,
in terms of overall records or,
sure, yeah. Yeah. So yeah, that's,
I mean a lot of fighters today in this
day and age don't fight nearly as many
times as they used to back in the day.
Like a guy like Floyd Mayweather who's
like 45 oh 46 and oh I think 46 in our
laughter, that's unbelievable. Like,
but 97 and oh that's so insane.
97 fights period, you know, and
that's right before he hit a loss.
And then I feel like, I could be
wrong, but I feel the wheels fell off.
That's actually the, one
of the quotes is, you know,
like on a long enough timeline.
Any, any fighting stories?
Usually it can be a tragic one.
And I find that happens less than MMA.
I feel like guys, no one to retire
better in MMA than inboxing.
I feel like people hang onto the rope
a little too close. That was true.
I wish it was really think it is. No,
no. Chocolate. Dell definitely didn't.
And I was almost going to
mention chuck Liddell was like,
because he did get rocked his last
couple of fights and that it's made some.
Yeah. Yeah. Well not just that.
The only reason why I stopped fighting
was Dana White because Dana just said
that's it. Yeah. Dan is very
close with them and said,
I see what's going on here and maybe
you don't because you're the fighter.
You got to stop.
The thing about fighters is they have
this belief in themselves and it's just,
it's never ending and unflappable
and especially the champions.
They always think,
I know everybody's count me out,
but I'm gonna figure out a
way to beat this motherfucker.
They go into that ring with
that determination. Yeah.
And that's what made them a
champion in the first place.
But that's also what that fails them.
When,
when it comes down to like
objective thinking and being
introspective about your
abilities and how much you've diminished,
it's that sort of bulletproof belief in
themselves that winds up fucking them
over. Yeah. And I think it's also
too there. They're young, right?
I mean comparatively, I know
my, when my dad retired, uh,
it was like a trap door open under his
life in a way because he was like used to
having this routine to his life and you
look forward to it. But I think, you know,
the first week you're like, oh, this is
great. And then the second week it's like,
what the, what the hell am
I doing? I feel like my,
and then if you're looking down the
barrel of that, when you're at 60, 65,
well that's one thing when you're
looking down the barrel of that,
when you're 32, 33 something like it's
gotta be a different, this is what I was,
this is what I'm good at.
This is all I'm good at.
I think some of them might think
and, and then it's like, God,
I've got a long existence ahead of
me doing what? What am I doing next?
And nothing is ever going
to match the thrill.
The fighting will never feel that or
I'll never feel something like that.
You know what I mean?
I feel like that must be,
I don't know if you've talked to fight,
did they ever,
are they good at describing
what that feeling is like? Well,
I think the only person that's ever going
to truly understand what it's like to
say like be Jon Jones and enter into a
world championship fight with the whole
world watching cage door
shuts and the Bruce buffer,
it's time. They're the only ones
that will ever understand that.
I will never understand it.
I've watched and I've done commentary and
more than a thousand right in the ring.
You're when the endorphins are still
there. When the fuck's going on,
I'm completely outside and I've competed.
I've kickbox and of course, yeah,
probably a hundred taekwondo matches.
Doesn't matter.
I just don't know what's going on when
that's happening. I just, I can't imagine.
I literally can't imagine. Do you think
it's a different level than cause I mean,
I mean it's a different level
in some way in the fat and the,
in the sort of the crowd response in
the idea of how many eyes are on you.
But I mean when you stepped in
or even when I've done fighting,
it's still you and another guy. So I
wonder how far removed is our experience.
You know what I mean? Pretty far
assume it is. Certainly in terms of,
but I mean I felt like I was amped
up to the point where every one of my
synapsis was screaming. I'm just not built
to do that. You know, maybe they have,
maybe there's a calmness.
I feel like sometimes you look
and they're the top fighters
are able to kind of establish a
certain calmness that, that I,
I've never really found.
And when in those situations in my life,
whether it's a playground scuffle or,
or you know, an amateur boxing match,
well the calmness,
a lot of it comes with the experience
itself being something that you recognize
and you've been there before and
you know how to deal with it.
Whereas someone who has never,
like if you took a guy who has never
competed at all before and you throw them
in a UFC fight, they would
fucking shit their pants. Yeah.
Especially if they didn't know how to
fight at all and there's so many things to
deal with, it would be overwhelming.
They probably have a heart attack. Yeah.
But if you take a guy like a Jon Jones,
because we keep talking about him,
trains his whole life in a wrestling.
So he's wrestled for many,
many years,
competed a very high level in wrestling,
then started competing
in MMA trains every day,
constantly in the gym, constantly working
out with these really high level guys.
It becomes,
you have a comfort level with like
just the recognition of what this is.
You understand it, you get in
there, you know what you can do,
you're very aware of what you're capable
of because you have literally pushed
yourself to your limits and training and
you get in there and you're much calmer
than a person who's completely
alien to the experience.
So I think for you like
doing it a couple of times,
like you didn't have a chance
to get used to it. No, not,
there's a lot of guys who do,
who are probably similarly
gifted or not gifted,
not gifted as the way a lot of
not gifted guys go very far.
Just through hard work and
determination and yeah. Yeah.
What they don't ever do is beat the
great ones. No, that's the difference.
The not gifted guys
can have great careers.
They can get a lot out of the competition.
They can become coaches,
they can train fighters, they
can, they can become commentators.
They can do a lot of things, but they
can never figure out a way to beat the
great one. No, no, no.
I feel like that's, um,
in my experience watching as well,
there's that kind of, that's,
that's a separation level. It's, it's
as much as your heart and your talent.
And there there is,
you know,
hearts is something that is one of
these ephemeral qualities that no one,
but I mean there is there, I mean
there are fighters that, you know,
that's what they have.
That's what's getting them through.
It's not necessarily they're talented.
They're,
I think heart is a combination of a lot
of things that are kind of impossible to
quantify. But you can, you can
see it in, in different athletes.
Doesn't have to be a fighter that seems
to be where it's most obvious to notice
it. But there's lots of
athletes that I like and,
and usually it's because they have some
quality of heart that distinguishes them
in my eyes. And it's, they're not
the best, but they're just there.
But they've taken their
skills as far as they can go.
Well that's why everybody loved Arturo
Gotti and make you worse. Of course,
those are the, that's a classic
to heart guys going up against.
Never quit. You can beat them up, you
could knock them out, you could stop them,
but there will was never what
faltered. No, no, absolutely.
And it had, they had more uh,
yeah.
Who knows what their limit would have
been necessarily or have they have trained
more intelligently repeated, more
intelligently. I mean a lot of that.
What, what is talent, you know, we'll,
it's the approach that you take.
If you look at the way Arturo God, he
moved and punched, he was very talented.
He was, wasn't it? Yeah,
most likely that he probably just wasn't
trained correctly or to the best of his
ability.
You know,
if you got a guy like a manual steward
who gets a hold of a boxer from the time
that he first starts and teaches him
just incredibly perfect technique,
perfect strategy. The
mindset, like a customer,
what he did with Mike Tyson molds
his mindset. You know, you can,
you can do something that if the
guy grows up with some, you know,
Midwest boxing club in the middle of
nowhere with a guy who doesn't really know
how to box and that's the guys teach him.
That's the guy brings it
through his amateur career.
And that's the guy who
turns him into a pro.
That guy might be lacking and just giant
chunks of knowledge that a guy like say
a Freddie Roach has.
Yeah. Yeah. You just, you,
you never know what would create a
champion out of a contender. Yeah.
Sometimes it's just the, it's
the, the mentor he runs in.
Yeah. I think that, I think that's,
and I, I feel like that's true. Yeah.
And also even mid fight,
you know,
because Gaddy was so many UCM sell drawn
into firefights when he didn't need to,
you know, and, and, uh,
whether he's really listening
to his trainer at that
point or not, I don't know.
Um, but I know for me to even, even the
amateur, uh, things that I did, what I,
what I really took away from it and
what I really enjoyed was that was the
training part of it. You know, I trained,
um, I was living in Iowa at the time and,
uh, there was, uh, a boxing club at
the bottom of like a really sort of,
it was at the bottom of a gold's gym
and Coral Hill, which is sort of like,
just outside of Iowa city. And, uh,
it was run by a coach and to
two girls to a female fighters,
the Kleinfelter sisters.
And they were like one 30,
one of them was maybe one 30. One of
them was like one 15, tough, I mean,
tough as nails fast and you'd,
you'd spar.
Like I knew I was going to have to
get in this amateur boxing match.
And so I was like, well, don't you
better not let be easy on me and I don't,
I did not going to be able to really punch
a girl. I didn't think, you know, and I,
I ultimately, I wasn't able to,
but even if I wanted to punch them,
I don't think I would have really been
able to lay leather on them because they
were fast and they were mean. And they
were, uh, and even if I did touch them,
they'd be like, you know, you, you
punch like a softy. Like this is weak,
weak ass shit. Uh, so, so,
but what I really took away from it is
really enjoying the, uh, the discipline,
you know, with nutrition and with
the roadwork. I mean, I could,
I did all that stuff.
I love doing that.
And I felt like that was the only thing
that I could actually take into my own
hands and that I had some sort of,
um, agency in, you know what I mean?
I can run as hard and as far and I can,
I can hit the bag for,
until my arms feel like noodles.
That's all that I can do.
And you'll see a direct,
improve your skills. But also
there was a limit. Like, I mean,
and the one thing that I noticed,
and I've said it before,
is like,
and I feel like other people have
noticed this because I've gotten a lot of
fights when I was young,
but I don't think I ever won one.
And I feel like I must exude this kind
of waft of something that like I just am
not a fighter,
but every time I've gotten in a fight,
it's been more that someone is,
I feel like it's taking,
trying to take advantage of me or has
been picking on me for a long period of
time. And it's the only way that this is
going to stop or have been or have been
picking on someone that I cared about.
And,
and I always got the sense afterwards
that the person who beat me up basically a
new, what? New? That they're like, they,
I can draw Davidson into a
fight and I'll, and, and he'll,
he'll willingly go in,
he'll go into the bear trap,
and then I'll just be able to beat him up.
And the only good thing about
it ultimately is that they,
the picking on stuff stopped,
you know what I mean?
But I had to take a beating in order
to sort of affect that, you know?
Yeah.
That's a weird psychological sort of a
relationship between the bully and the,
the person who gets picked on.
Yeah. Yeah. But I feel like,
and I feel like the real true fighters
wouldn't even do something like that.
They would recognize
why, you know, this guy,
or I'm not going to bother with this guy.
I mean, I have mother. Yeah. I mean, May,
may, I don't know. Maybe,
maybe there are some writers who like to
beat the shit out of people. Yeah. Yeah.
You've,
I'm even noticing fight sometimes I feel
like that guy looks like he probably
might have, would be happy to be
beating up someone with far less skill.
He taking as much delight in it as he is.
Usually they'd been abused. Is that so,
yeah. I believe that's a big
part of, uh, a lot of what,
what constitutes a bully is
physical abuse. You know,
that they've been abused either at home
or they've been abused by other kids and
they're trying to lash out and get theirs.
Now they've sort of taken on the role of
the bully because they've been bullied
so much. That happens a lot. I could
see that. I actually, here's the,
here's the sort of a story of
my, one of my worst beatings. Uh,
I was at the YMC hey,
me and my brother were playing basketball.
That was probably like
16, 17, eight times my,
of my last year of high school probably.
And these two guys come and say, let's,
let's play two on two. So we did, and
back then I probably weighed like two 40.
I was, uh, I was a big fat dude, you
know, I just tee it 40 in the high school.
Yeah, maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe two 30,
like I was enormous, but it was not a,
it was not a healthy weight obviously.
What do you weigh now? One 75,
one eight or something like that.
So that's partly the whole boxing stuff.
And we do tree planting
a lot up in Canada.
That's sort of like what
you do at university.
You just go up to the woods
and plant trees and that.
I shed a lot of weight that way,
uh, during, during university.
But so I was a big beast,
you know,
and I sort of knew how to use my body and
the guy that I was playing against was
maybe one, one 60. Um,
so we were getting close to beat them
and I turned around and I see the ball,
it's whipping right at my face.
He'd thrown it at me and I turned my head
and it sort of goes by the side of my
head and just, you know, it gives
me a scalp basically. And then he's,
then he's charging right at me.
Like to get in no fight. Um,
and there was no pro prior product? No,
none at all. That's the thing. I mean,
this guy, just a basketball, just a
basketball game and, and, and, okay.
It's in the why. So I'm like, okay,
well we're not going to have a fight
right in the middle of the why.
I think I'm going to be
okay. That's, I mean,
I didn't really want to get into a fight,
but again,
this guy's throwing a basketball. I mean,
it's pretty shitty move. So anyways,
this guy comes out,
he's gotta be like 80 years old.
He's like one of those guys at the y
that was like a retired gym teacher and
they sort of said, okay bill, you can
just hang out around here and keep order.
That's the be nice of you to do that.
So he comes out and he's got a whistle
around like an old p whistle around his
neck, knee. He says, take it
outside. I'm like, I don't,
the last thing I want to do is take this
outside, but, and, and, and he says,
that's it guys. You take this
outside. So I'm like, Oh,
I'm sort of like being shoe horned into
going out to having a fight with this
guy. So I'm going down the hallway
and my brother is, he should,
he's massaging my shoulders cause I
guess he thinks that's what he should be
doing. You know, that's how little we
know about fighting. You know what I mean?
He's, my brother was like,
well I guess I've seen this
in rocky. I should keep him,
keep him limber and you know, he's like,
you're, you're going to be fine. And if I,
but I had a chance to look in his
eyes, he'd be like, you are, you are,
you are fucked. You know what I
mean? And I, I think I knew that too.
So I ended up outside, it's winter
in Canada and there's ice on the,
on the, on the sidewalk. And you know, I,
I face up and what I assume is somewhat
somewhat of a fighting posture.
And he kicks me in the head.
It's the first thing he does just
like kicked me right in the head.
And I'm not even sure what that will
happen. I'm still standing, you know,
and they need does it again. And
then I'm like, Oh God, this is not,
this is not good. So he had martial arts
training. Yeah, definitely. And then,
you know, there was a bike rack.
And I remember he like rang my,
my head off of it and I'd get them in
a, you know, sort of a headlock. And,
uh, and I remember being like face down
and there's like ice melts on the street,
you know, that those blue crystals
they put down, you know, and I'm, I'm,
my face is pressed into it and thankfully
it goes on for a while. Clearly I'm,
I'm beat. And he's like, are you, are we,
are we had enough here? I'm like, yeah,
I mean, I've, I've had
enough. That's enough.
So he goes back inside
chuckling with his buddy. Um,
I'm sitting out there
on the street bleeding.
I don't even want to go back into the why,
you know what I mean?
I'm going to have the people inside going,
what the hell happened?
Do you need help? And I'm like, I just
want to crawl into a hole and, you know,
not see humanity for about a month.
Uh, so my brother goes inside,
gets my clothes, we go, I
find out later, this guy,
we lacrosse is a big sport in our,
in our country.
And he was like the enforcer
on the Lacrosse Lacrosse team,
like the triple a Lacrosse team.
So he was a tough guy.
Like I didn't have a chance.
You know right from the get go,
I didn't have a chance.
And then, you know,
I discover his name cause we lived
in a small town. And you sort of,
these things sort of come to you,
uh, as time goes by and then, um,
my buddy calls me up,
but a couple of years later he says,
did you hear about so and so? I said, no,
I was away at university at this point.
He's like, they went camping in
the woods and hit him and his dad.
And this word gets back to your idea
of abuse. He stabbed his dad 44 times,
killed him,
killed him in the woods and they caught
him just walking down the street with
the knife in his hand. And, uh, and
you know, later on the interview,
his mom and his mom was like,
yeah, he was, uh, you know,
he basically would sit out
on the porch saying that he,
George Bush was going to come
in air force one anytime,
pick them up for some top secret mission.
So we clearly had some,
some mental instabilities that didn't
present themselves at the age at which at
least they were maybe emerging,
but later,
I mean that part had never been been into,
I'm not,
I can't really comment
on that, but I mean, I,
I don't know, but I think I feel
like he stabbed the man 44 times.
He would have to be a really heated
argument and if they had no prior sort of
history with one another, I
don't, I don't really know.
But first of all that he stabbed him
and then he stabbed him that many times.
Holy Shit. Yeah. And I thought a thought
later, like, man, as bad as I got it,
I mean, I could've gotten a lot
worse. You know what I mean?
At least he let me off at the
end. He's like, all right, well
I always try to explain that someone
who gives people the finger in a car,
like you never know who you're
giving the finger to. Exactly. My,
my wife has a bad habit of
honking the horn. I'm like,
baby, I love you, but don't,
don't do it.
Don't do it.
Don't you don't know who
the hell is stepping out of
that fricking car. You know,
not only that,
you never know what state they're in.
They can be in the worst state of mind
ever at the moment you lay on that horn,
you could have caught them
at the breaking point. Yeah.
And that's what puts them fucking people.
Especially in this day and age when
you're dealing with cities and traffic and
the unnatural stress of slamming 200
fucking million people together like this.
Yeah. Yeah. They've done these
studies on, on population density, um,
just with rats and they've shown how
bizarre rat behavior gets when you get too
many rats and contained environment.
And it mirrors human being's
behavior as far as like human beings,
when you have a small amount of them,
you know,
everybody seems to get along fine,
but when you jam them together,
you started getting all
these mental illnesses. Well
that's what they do with a,
they get rats. If you have a certain
amount of rats and you jam them into a,
a box there,
a certain amount of,
and we'll just sit in the corner and
start nodding their heads up and down and
back and forth and then
it gets really hard.
Yeah. Yeah. I found that same thing.
I used to work at a place called
marine land in Niagara Falls,
which is like a seaworld.
Yeah. We had a guy I'm on that worked
at marine. Oh really? Yeah, yeah.
Was involved in,
um,
this fucking horrible situation with,
uh,
with dolphins and he had to the fuck is
his name, Phil. Phil DeMaurice. Oh, Shit.
You got him. I interviewed him for an
article. I did feel dimmers. Yeah. Okay.
Of course. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. And
he was explaining us the smoosh it all
smooshy Walrus. Walrus, yeah. Yeah.
It was also explained to
us how intelligent these
dolphins are and the dolphins
go on hunger strikes.
They have to force feed them and that
they take them away from their mothers and
they buy them from Russians.
Yeah. Or really ruthless
the way they, they capture.
Yeah. Yeah. I know it's, it's, it's, it's
rough. It's rough stuff. Yeah. So anyway,
you got, you got all that already from
Phil and Phil was an insider. Phil was,
Phil was there after I was there
and I think things got some,
I mean it was never a trainer either,
but you know,
some of the things that those guys are,
the animal control guys
saw was pretty rough.
But that same thing as you perhaps so
many animals and if you did the same to
people, of course there's going to
be like mania, disturbing, you know,
depression, all sorts of stuff that
we can sort of emote. You know,
animals can only sort of just
do it through their behavior.
You get a sense of like this is not right,
this, this rat is not in a good state.
Well the zoo,
you ever go to the zoo and watch an animal
just pace back and forth and they're
small little container. Yeah.
And you're like, this is nuts.
I watched this bear once and he would
just walk to one area turnaround,
walk to the other, turn around
and go back and forth. Like,
that animal is going mad. They're
good. They're going, Matt there,
their animals like bears,
they roam over miles and miles,
countryside. And that's how
their genes are sort of adopted.
They're,
they're adapted rather their,
their whole being is adapted
to this idea of nature,
providing them with food.
They go out and forge for the food.
When they just stuck in his box and the
food comes sliding under the door and a
tray every day, all their reward
systems are being rude up,
just ignored or contain that some
strange sort of a way and madness.
No, no, exactly. It, they, and
they find other ways, you know,
when you baffled all of those primal
instincts. Mm. Um, and I think, you know,
it's true. I, I, you know, we have a son
and will we take them to the Toronto zoo?
I mean, we might have to, where else can
you see all of those creatures? You know,
you can't just go out, you know, searching
the forest until you find a bear.
I mean you could. Um, but you,
you do it with the understanding that no
matter how nice the bear Penn is or the
gorilla enclosure it, you can't, it can't
do all the things that that gorilla,
you just have to hope that they have a
mind that is a bit more able to embrace
their new situation.
And some animals may be can,
but other animals just like
I'm built for this. And same,
same with some men who were
imprisoned. Like I'm not, you know,
with the cool hand Luke sort of a
thing. I'm not built for this. Yeah.
It ain't happening.
Yeah, I agree. I, I, and I have children
and I take them to the zoo, but the,
is that feeling like I
do it just cause my kids,
I want them to explore everything,
see as many things as possible.
But this is part of me that feels like
a big hypocrite because I don't want to
support contain these animals.
Yeah.
Fucking penguin and it's 90 degrees
out in la, like says fuck penguin.
Thinking no one's going to be
like, what am I doing here? What?
How did I get here anyways? Like, why is
it so lights went out and I'm, yeah, who's
this guy in the blue suit feed me
fish and the fish are dead already.
Yeah. Fuck what's going on? Well,
even getting them to learn to do that,
like I think a lot of animals just end
up starving because they just won't learn
to eat an animal that's not,
you know,
they're normally used to catching in some
way. So you can't fake their enclosure.
They can't,
they can't embrace that much of a change.
Well, also the, the,
the reality of zoo life is completely
alien to the reality of an animal existing
in an ecosphere. Yeah. Or in an ecosystem.
So when an animal is in a zoo,
that animal is separated from every
other species, which never happened.
No, no. Absolutely. Just so
bizarre. And not only that,
there's nothing trying to kill them.
So they don't learn anything. No.
All of their natural
instincts to avoid predators,
to sorta like sit there. They don't,
they don't experience predators.
Every monkey experiences.
Predators, every ape experiences,
cats in the wild there.
There's no apes that live anywhere where
there's not something that my fuck them
up, whether it's a spider or a snake
that they should avoid or something,
and they have to learn. You learn to
keep away from that snake. That's Nigga,
fuck you. Yeah, but that's what keeps
them sharp. Exactly what I mean.
That's what gives them
their lives purpose really.
Even if it's just surviving well,
it makes sure that the good
genes pass on and in the zoo,
it's just dumb monkeys walking each other.
No one learns anything.
They give free peanuts,
just they just,
that's what they're breeding and
weirdest form of like animal prison ever.
It's very strange.
No. Yeah, I mean I agree,
but again, you got kids.
I mean you do all sorts of
weird things for your kids.
I think sometimes zoos exist,
but for the benevolence of of
kids or the needs of kids so that,
so that parents feel like,
well shit, you're not going
to see this any other way.
I love you. I want you to see them.
I'll gloss over. I'll say, oh,
look at the happy monkeys.
Even though in some part of you knows,
these are not happy monkeys, the, this
is not natural either. But you know,
you're not going to take them to Borneo
either. A natural monkeys. Yeah, exactly.
Monkeys, you'll steal your
name. I will eat your kid. Um,
there's been stories of chimps
stealing babies that's, oh,
there was an awful article in
Esquire where these two, you know,
two people couldn't, couldn't have kids,
so they, they get, get a chimp, you know,
and the chimp,
they raise the chimp like it's their kid
and then they have probably had the gym
for like 20 years. One day the chimp
goes nuts, tears her face off, basically.
Like chimps are incredibly strong,
powerful creatures and
um, you know, basically,
you mean she survived, but just
barely sort of a thing. Um,
and you don't recognize that,
those sort of things.
I think when I think of chimps, I think
of that movie with Clint Eastwood. Uh,
what every which way we're an orangutan,
but,
and those are probably even even
tougher, you know? I mean, they're,
they're bigger creatures, but they're
less violent though. Are they?
They're more subdued sort of a thing.
Well, they'll still fuck you up. Don't dot
your i's and crossing the t's,
but they don't actively seek out
fucking up other animals. Chimps.
Do chips have an instinct to go out
and kill things? Sure. Yeah. Chimps.
Chimps are not, um,
they're not herb before us.
Like a lot of people
have this misconception.
I had that up until this very
moment. Predators, they eat monkeys,
the monkeys alive. Oh,
Jesus. Never seen that.
Never too dark.
That would be dark because they didn't
heating a little version of themselves.
Basically. God, well, they cannibalize
as well. Oh, do they really?
They murder other chimps and
they cannibalize other chimps.
They cannibalized chimp babies.
I got chimps are the worst
aspects of human beings, um,
like in an animal form with
intelligence and the I,
but I think that is what makes people
want to adopt them because it's the
closest thing to us. That's
not us. You know what I mean?
What's weird is that bonobos are close
cousins and they don't exhibit any of
that behavior. But what they do is they
fuck each other like crazy. Oh, really?
Everybody fucks. They fuck everybody.
The father's fuck the daughters,
the brothers fuck there. The, there are
other brother. They fucked their sons.
Everybody fucks. Really, it just like
a big clan of, yeah, just uh, you know,
sort of incest all over the,
well,
so much so that it's kind
of clever on their part.
They've avoided captivity because of it,
because you can't have them in the
zoo because they just fun. Right.
People are like, we can't show our kids
is fucking apes. Yeah. Go and go on.
Add it all the time. Which is so weird.
It's so ironic that you can, you know,
you can have these animals doing
everything in the wild except breeding.
We can't tolerate that show. Our
children breeding. Yeah, exactly.
They only have the like the hand
as they want that or what does it,
there's one group that they desperate to
find them to hand as they're trying to
get them to breed.
The only thing that they do do avoid is
the mothers will not have sex with their
sons. That's the only one
where it's verboten. Yeah,
the Banabos have that one
rule for whatever reason.
The mother does not want to have
sex with her son and that's it.
But everything else is fair game.
Everything else on the table and you won't
ever see that in the zoo because they
just are like, you guys just exist
in the wild where we're okay,
we're okay with our chimps and are
gorillas and resolve conflict by fucking,
yeah,
so like sort of a prime like sort of
like that's how they express dominance.
Kind of an idea that way. Or even like,
I'm sure we argued here, but let's have,
let's fuck around heroin. Everything's
all right. You don't know.
I mean I would probably have
to study it a lot, but they do.
Do a lot of chimp like things where
they pick up branches and smack branches
around and they'll pick up a large branch
and they drag it on the ground to show
dominance.
Chimps do a lot of that.
They do a lot of posturing with
picking up large things, shaking trees.
I'll shake things to show how
strong they are. But chimps,
we'll engage in like some serious
violence. I was elbows. Yeah.
Well maybe if you want to, I mean, I
guess if you were into adopting it,
the one part of that story,
like you understand like
you have kids, but you know,
I have kids.
I think if you don't have kids
and you've tried to have kids,
I think people might feel that there's
a loss in their life and something that
needs to be filled. You know, and
often you fill it with an animal,
you get really into dog
breeding or [inaudible] 17
cats or something like that.
These guys decided to,
chimp was the way to go.
And I guess I would have
thought like totally innocently
that, yeah, okay. A chimp,
whatever. You dress it up in a Tuxedo.
And, uh, do whatever. It's a little weird,
but I get the,
I get why you're doing it.
I know it's a replacement for the
fact that you can't have kids,
but then when this kid goes
a feral on you basically and,
and attacks you in a way that,
um,
documentary about people
that keep scary animals.
It's called the elephant in the living
room and it's supposed to be really good.
I got an 82% on rotten tomatoes.
I need to watch it,
but it's a documentary about the
raising of exotic pets in homes and, uh,
how many knuckleheads in America wind up
doing that? They, you know, they have,
like,
there was this thing the other day,
I was watching this piece on this
guy who has a pet mountain line,
really bottle fed it since it was a baby.
And you see at least in a sort of a
remote area or, I don't know. I don't,
I didn't pay attention off,
but he's got this cat,
he's had it since it was a baby and now
it's a full grown 200 pound female cat
and just like, yeah, okay. Yeah.
Hope that works out. Thank
you. Are Juggling dynamite
right here, my friend. But uh,
nappy, you know, I mean I don't know
what I'm, some animals are cool with it,
you know, as long as you feed them
and your sweet with them. But yeah,
the bottom line is it's always going
to have that instinct to chase shit.
If you roll a ball of yarn in front of
a take a ball of yarn and toss it in
front of a house cat, they
fucking dive on that. Yeah,
yeah. Oh yeah. Total open. No, no, exactly
like a laser pointer on the wall there.
But yeah, there are bananas. You
can't, that's their instinct, you know.
So and we have one who comes home
with all manner of like cats are,
you can't beat cats for like Sorta,
just like sadism. Oh, they've worked.
Came home once. It was night and I was
like, what do you got there in your mouth?
And she opens her mouth and
it was a baby mouse alive.
She just cradled it in her mouth like,
but I realized if I'd come five,
she was just going to play with it until
it either died of fright or punctual.
Yeah. She chewed it up
basically. So I think like a dog,
a dog just goes and gets what it wants.
Eats it. Most animals do. But man,
a house cat especially cause they're,
all their needs are covered.
So it's like this is all just fun for me.
My cat
grew up a mouse once. Ah,
he had eaten it and uh,
then just puked it in the living room.
Yeah, that's rough. She, yeah. Yeah.
Ours or ours or girls instead of a male
cat too. But it wasn't a male cat that,
that it was a female. She just
barfed it up. Little mini mouse.
Oh that's terrible. Cat Food.
Narrow. Hairballs yeah. I'm like,
oh you discussed monster fucking weird
because they're looking at you like the
parent and everything. I was rubbing
up against you. Like they're so sweet.
But you think, man, if I was an inch
tall, you would make sport out of me.
You would make mince meat out
of me and you would have no,
not a goddamn care in the world.
No. No, no remorse. No,
no remorse. All it was,
I enjoy reading, reading. Uh,
it's just cut into this last week a
reading Vegan forums on how to feed their
cats and they almost all reluctantly have
to admit that their cats need meat is
CATSA very high protein requirements and
much different than a human beings and
much different even than a dog.
He can,
you can feed dogs like a certain amount
of Vegan food and, and the vegans,
do they say
we're, we're, this is a
Vegan, Vegan household and it,
that counts on our dogs and cats as well.
Do what? Their dogs. Wow. People
get away with it with their dogs.
They don't get away with it.
The cat.
Yeah. That's just, there
just wouldn't be healthy.
You'd like mistreatment
animals like this all day.
I need some time,
but this mangy looking for
fallen out and oh, he's fine.
He's just kind of going through a stage,
just reading the,
the torment that these people have gone
through before they make the decision to
feed.
Yeah, I know, I can imagine.
I can only imagine, you know,
I had one to Iot, I was trying to do
a, an article on, um, on pit bulls,
which I thought would've been
really interesting cause I,
one thing I noticed it
in research was like,
people in different parts of this country
breed pit bulls differently based on
where they are from. Like Kentucky,
Arkansas, they breed like a really lean,
it's almost like fighters, like a really
lean fast version of a dog. Whereas in,
in California, uh, or sorry, Florida
and Miami area, they be your breed,
like really big,
bulky kind of that sort of what the
genes that they want to put together and
yeah, for the purposes of, of fighting
these creatures. Um, and I mean I,
I, I like pit bulls. I've
met, I've met not, you know,
nice pit bulls, you know. Um,
but I do,
I do know from what I've researched,
any ways that they're like bred into,
they're built to be fighting creatures
that sort of what they were bred for it.
Um, and not sort of what that's
exactly what they were bred for.
And so that sort of thing is always
in there is, is in their DNA helix.
It's sort of, it's sunk
in there and uh, you know,
you go onto these pitbull forums and
you experience in the same way with Veg,
like a very strong emotional kind of like,
you don't understand, you don't get it.
And I wasn't even coming from a
perspective of like intolerance or hatred.
I was just coming from a
perspective of I just want it,
would like to talk about it.
Where do you go to a pit bull fighting
forum and what wasn't fighting.
This was what they do
with this one was um,
they in sort of like
tracked your pulse for dogs.
Oh they hook them up to
sledges and they see how much,
how many bricks they can carry
and, and that sort of like, I mean,
I'd much rather that, right. Just like
strength events basically for these dogs.
But I, I, I, I sort of had the
temerity I guess to, to say, you know,
you guys,
I hope I can see why you're doing this.
You're sort of doing this because these
dogs have these instincts and it's
better to have them pulling a
sledge then fighting, you know,
fighting one another or fighting
other dogs and you know, you're,
you're just sort of assaulted
by these people who are like,
you don't get it at all. These are the
nicest creatures ever. And I wasn't
even coming from saying there. They're
not nice creatures. You know, I, I, again,
I feel like a lot of it with
animal ownership is the owner.
It's really not the dog always,
you know,
a dog when it's born can go
any number of different ways.
But when you see a a pit bull owned by
a guy who's driving around like a jacked
up pickup truck and his dog's got like
a spike collar on and he's carrying
around by a links of know chain,
you're like,
that dog might potentially have been
raised with a certain higher you.
The aggression might've been brought out
of a more than this dog that had grown
up with the family with three kids in it,
you know? Yeah, they can be good pets,
but they're always dangerous.
Run other dogs. Always.
Almost always very rare that you get
a pit bull that doesn't have animal
aggression.
Just thousands of years of genetics.
They're raised them to be
aggressive and to fight other dogs.
I love pit bulls as pets,
but I won't have them
just because it's a drag.
Like your friend brings their dog over
and your dogs don't play. They go to war,
you know? Exactly. It's not exactly
if it's two pimples, it's one thing.
But if your friend brings over his
black lab at ain't it ain't a fight.
Not a fight. And I went, I did a,
went into the SPCA and they just busted
a ring and they had like 40 fighting
dogs and they were so nice
around the Spca workers, all the,
but they end up having to,
to destroy.
Most of them were maybe all of them even
because it's, it is, it's like having a,
uh,
a stick of dynamite with a
fuse of indeterminate link
that could blow up at any
time,
you know,
and they just felt like you had been
bred to this sort of utility and this is
what you're good for and it's
not your fault, but you're just,
you're not safe out in general population.
And also,
if they're not trained properly,
can be very dangerous around children
because they don't recognize children's
adults.
Uh,
well they'll acquiesce to an
adult's demands and requests.
They look at adults as being
the ones that are in control.
They don't look at children along
those same lines. They see something,
their height and they just attack it. Ah,
that's fucking really, Dang. It is. It is.
And, and I mean, again, there's going
to be people listening to this who are,
or Pippo fanciers and they're going to,
I've had a bunch of them. Have you? Yeah.
Who have,
who have had half had words about this
or have they know I've had pit bulls,
pit bulls yourself. I came home once. My
dog had killed my dog in the living room.
You're kidding. No, they went
to war when I was gone. Jesus,
believe me, man. I'm, I'm, I love them as
animals. I will never have them as pets.
Not Anymore. Yeah. So you've got kids
now too. Of course. I didn't have kids.
I just deal with it, get it out and
attack the neighbor's dog or something.
That happened to my dogs.
Dad got out of his yard,
crawled into the neighbor's yard,
attack the neighbor's dog and the animal
control guys came over and killed it.
It's fucked. It's like, first of all,
it's fucked for the neighbor. You know,
the dog's barking. Like dogs bark at each
other and they're thinking, you know,
Shit. Dogs like, oh, for real,
fighting to the death of the, I'm
already in your yard. It is to the death.
That's the only way I know you with
the guy in the basketball. You're like,
Holy Shit, I'm, I'm up against
the different breed of humanity.
Right guys kicking me in the
head. Yeah. Nowhere. And you know,
you're just trying to play basketball and
your brother's rubbing your shoulders.
Neither one of you know,
what the fuck are you doing?
How are totally neophytes and, and you
know, and there was something, you know,
this is probably way too like writerly,
but there is something about the eyes
of a guy like that and you're just like,
oh, I'm, you know, you know, you're
done before you're done. I haven't, no,
you're done before. Hundreds
of those dudes. Yeah.
There's just something clockwork
in around in their eyes like,
and you're just like, oh no, no, no,
I'm not, I'm not built to this standard.
This is not going to work
out too well for me. Yeah.
There's guys that enjoy beating the
fuck out of people. And like I said,
a lot of them have had the fuck
beaten out of them and it becomes,
and that's one of the things that they
say that's the most horrific thing about
sexual abuse,
is that a lot of the abused become
abusers when they get older. Exactly.
It started like a repetitive of the sun.
Ray expresses the sins
of the father so dark.
It's such a weird thing how it makes
you realize too. Just how fortunate.
Like I again,
I know you,
you spoke about your mom and you have
a good relationship with your mom.
I did a good relationship with your
father as well. No, no. Terrible. Oh,
I don't know him.
He was a horrible guy.
But my experience up until
I was five years old,
it was just him being really violent
and scary to, to both you and your mom.
Mostly to my mother. Not
really to me, but uh,
enough so that it was just a
scary thing to watch. Yeah.
Well, so, you know, I mean,
I would just very
fortunate you realize how
luck is based on so many things that
just who your parents are, where,
where you're born in the world.
And uh, um, and uh, yeah, I didn't,
I've been very fortunate that way, but
I know friends who have had, you know,
different situations so,
but anyways, yeah, yeah.
I mean it's just
get your hand in life.
You do what with with it what you can,
but some people's hand is
just unmanageable and that
is just the reality of
being a human being.
There are certain people that are just
abused to the point of no return before
they ever get a chance to
try to sort their life out.
I wouldn't even begin to know how to
manage that. I wouldn't know what to do.
And I know people that have, uh,
adopted, uh, abused kids and you know,
the kid is,
they've had the kids since the kid
was three and then the kids now a in
kindergarten and fucked the gets fucked.
No. In My, uh, my, my wife is out,
the child services social worker,
which I mean, it's tough. It's tough.
And she told me this one
story, I can repeat it. Um,
and she, she goes over
with this, this other, uh,
with a cop actually to apprehend
these kids, opens the door, dirt bag.
Father answers it. My kids aren't here,
kids haven't been here for days. Uh,
she's like, well, we
have reports that your,
your wife said that they are here because
they're certainly not with your, your,
your ex. And you know, basically
they had a warrant. They got inside
rooms, empty apartments, empty as far as
they could tell. Closets, open closets,
open a jar.
So they open it up to kids in there,
in the closet.
And the one thing that my wife
noticed was it the wallpaper,
I don't know who wallpapers the
inside of closet, but whatever,
it was ripped and rags and the kids had
been eating anything because they had
been in there for so long that,
that, that was sort of how
it, how it came that way.
They got to the point where they were,
or they were eating the wall
paper listening to this podcast recently,
that there's this podcast that I
really enjoy called radio lab. And uh,
one of the episodes or radio lab
dealt with this guy. Um, the,
the episode's called escape, uh, dealt,
dealt with this guy who had spent
his entire life in and out of jail.
And it was about his,
uh,
his childhood and how he was sort
of abandoned. He was raised by,
I forget what relative, but they didn't
feed them. And so him and his dog,
his sister would eat paper at night
just to fill their stomachs because they
were an agony from hunger pains.
Yeah, yeah. Do you know you,
you read about shit like that and this,
you know,
this guy goes on this horrific cycle of
childhood abuse and becomes as criminal
and,
and he wound up meeting this woman falling
in love and actually having a family
but still keeps fucking up and
can't figure out a way to stop.
And you hear it from the woman, you
know, like the woman who married him.
Her point of view of like
what could he do? Look,
I grew up like in this horrific
state and he just, he's broken.
He's a broken man.
It's fucked.
And it's,
yeah.
It's like before we even had a chance
really to make his own decision about some
of these things. Um, yeah. Yeah. I know.
I don't mean to be a Downer about
any of this. Yeah. Yeah. As a writer.
I that what I was gonna ask earlier,
okay.
About watching things that you,
you know,
watching humans that you don't
agree with or watching things,
studying human behavior.
When you do that,
do you try to put yourself in the mind
of the abused or the mind of the abuser?
Like,
do you try to put yourself into these
people's heads to try to see what was like
this guy who, you know, they found him
and you know, he's saying like, no,
my kids aren't here.
And then they find the kids in the closet.
Do you try to put yourself in
that guy's mind? No.
Eight mean in that case,
I put myself in the mind of the
social worker because Ma, you know,
it was easier to,
for me to put myself in the mind of,
of my wife rather than put myself in
the mind of, of someone like that.
You know what I mean? But
even in the troupe, there's,
there's a character Shelly
who is, uh, you know,
has some very serious things
wrong with him. Uh, and um, so,
so yeah,
I think part of it is trying to put
yourself as closely into that mindset as,
as you can,
um,
while recognizing that you can
never quite bridged that gap.
You know what I mean?
Cause cause I mean,
that's just the leap that I
can't quite make, you know,
so you just have to hope that,
that you're getting close enough that uh,
that the reader is always said as,
as a writer,
you just need to be one
step ahead of your reader.
It means you have to have done that a
little bit more to more research or just
spent more time thinking about
these things that a reader,
hopefully it's going to
read really quickly and it's
going to be like, okay, okay.
It's not, nothing is really
sticking out. That is enough.
That's going to make them sort of checkup,
which all people do in a book or a
movie. They're like, okay, you've just,
this is too far.
You suddenly you've sort of cross some
sort of boundary that I'm no longer quite
with you in the way that I was before. Um,
and you never know what it like. I was,
I was,
you know,
having dinner yesterday at the hotel bar
and ended up next to this guy talking
to him and he was like a big Tom
Clancy reader. And, and I said,
Oh, I've had people, like I had a guy
get in touch with me once. Uh, cause I,
I wrote some sort of book that had some
military stuff in it and he was sorry,
said, well, you know, um, and not to,
not to be a nitpicker anything, but the,
the clip capacity of an m 16 is actually
16 rounds and not 17, as you said.
And I'm like, I get it. I
mean, I get it. I get that.
That's wrong. That's a mistake.
Um,
but I think probably the store,
that's what I'm trying to
do is not really having,
it'd be great if I could have caught
that and it was more scrupulous to fact,
but really you're trying to weave a
narrative and fiction, but some readers,
that's what they want. They want to take
this out of it. If you don't, exactly.
If you don't get the facts right,
if you don't,
if you're doing something about
medical stuff and you're not,
you haven't been scrupulous
about it, then, um, then yeah,
then you're going to get,
but I mean, the guy mentioned, he's like,
that's why I can't read Stephen King
because he gets apparently too many things
wrong.
And I'm like,
I am so deep into most
Stephen King narratives that
I don't wonder what he gets
wrong. I wonder that too. I, I, I sort
of asked him and he wasn't able to,
he wasn't able to say anything.
It was just a generalized sentiment
that's not who gets things wrong.
There go much to be a dick, a wine.
He might've been, he was, he was,
uh,
he was a defense contractor.
He sounds like a dick if
he can't tell you the exact
things that Stephen King got wrong,
like any particular examples,
he's gotta be a dickhead.
Yeah.
Well,
and sometimes you just find yourself
faced up against so many said something
like, well, uh, you know, fracking, you
know, fracking. And he's like, well,
I've done research and there's absolutely
not a damn thing wrong with fracking.
And it's a myth. Just like global warming
is a myth. And I was like, oh, okay.
I think we're probably on different sides
of this and I'm not going to get into
an argument with you about it,
but that's where you just tune out of a
conversation. He was like, oh, okay. I'm,
I'm, I'm out of fracking or not a myth.
No. I mean, people are light up their,
their tap water. I don't know
if you're seeing that, you know,
people have been able to
do that.
I've looked pretty deeply into it.
People have been able to light up their
tap water long before there was fracking.
It is possible that, well
water is getting, is getting
the, they get contaminated,
but the reality of contaminated,
well,
water's directly related to fracking
is undeniable because they're,
they're blown out the earth and then it's
seeping through until the end of the,
yeah. They're all, and they're
getting better at fracking.
They're figuring out a way to do it
that's more efficient. But the reality is,
you know,
you've got to break some eggs to make an
omelet and guys don't give a fuck. Yeah.
They're trying to get natural resources
out of the ground and they're not trying
to not pollute.
They're just doing their best to confirm,
to conform to whatever regulations
that get established. Yeah.
That allow them to make money.
And those regulations are directly
influenced by the very companies that make
fucking trillions of dollars.
They own the politicians,
they buy all the regulations.
They make sure that everything is in place
so that they can make money. Totally.
I mean, there's definitely some
damage that fracking has done.
Did the question becomes, is it okay?
Is it okay that this damage is done?
Because there's a plus side,
there's, there are employee. Yeah.
There's a lot of natural gases and a
lot of natural resources that we could
harvest. And that's different question.
Yeah. But the idea that it's a,
it's a myth and there's nothing wrong
with fracking. That guy's a dick.
Those,
those
fucking right wing chatterboxes.
Yeah. Yeah. And it just come
right out with it too. I'm,
but then like two minutes of
us talking, I'm like, wow,
now suddenly I'm not getting into this
where he's an idiot. He's an idiot.
The idea that global warming is a myth
too. He's an idiot. Yeah. I feel like,
come on. It's pretty well established
and whether or not it's human influenced.
There's, that's a debate
that most scientists almost,
I think it's some insane number,
like 99% think that it's human
influence and since he's not okay
fucking science,
maybe you should shut is dirty hall.
Yeah. And I feel, I felt almost
like a fuck, I hate to say Joe,
but like a bit of a fraud that I
didn't go up against them, you know,
because you're like, I would've walked
away. Yeah. You can't fight every battle.
But there's a sense of like,
cause that's the conservative
thing is like to come right at you.
And I feel like, well fuck if I don't,
if I don't come back and say something,
I've started just like let him believe
that his point is valid for the
perspective.
Nadian you're a liberal,
you wear glasses.
I know fucking hates you or I,
it was amazing.
Even spoke to me in the first place and
we spoke to you to correct you. Correct.
You and Stephen King and he's fucking
pussies are scared of fracking.
You're worried about global warming.
I'm going to buy land up in your country.
Meanwhile,
you know,
they don't understand that global warning.
It changes both the
cold and the warm though
cold gets colder. Yeah. That's one of
the big arguments is like, well look at,
look at w you know, you'd look at how
cold it is now. We had a hell of a winter.
Then understand it's like you don't,
it's the fluctuations that are,
what are the things you are
need to be looking at, you
know? But whatever. It's a,
it's a worthless sort of
thing to get into. You know,
especially with this guy had to be
like Donald Sterling's age. It ain't,
it ain't worth fighting. It Ain't
worth it. He's an old that point.
You should have scared him and see
if he'd give him a heart. Right.
Sorry.
If he could
get his little fucking shit tickers going.
Yeah.
And enough of you with your
defense contracting and
your global warming denying.
Ah, yeah. I know you just sort of feel
like, well at least I don't think,
I think you're too old to have too much
of a sway in this other than your vote
still counts as much as mine does.
Talking to guys like
that, just to find out what makes
them draw those conclusions.
But what I'm always fascinated
by is not on the show.
You've got people who,
you know,
have contrary positions to what it,
but you're able to engage with them,
I think in a really, really
interesting at way that's not terribly,
it's confrontational, but it's not, I
dunno, I didn't know how to describe it.
Right. But I've seen you do it and it's a,
it's a skill obviously. Yeah. Well, I, uh,
I like to talk to people that have strong
beliefs and systems and things rather
to find out what were the,
how their belief systems are formed.
I want to know that if there's,
is there a logical,
rational sort of basis to their belief
systems or is it just that they've sort
of adopted this predetermined pattern,
which is very common? Very much so. Yeah.
I had a conversation with a guy in
Jujitsu class about global warming we was
talking to, and he just, he's 24 years
olds, a military kid, and he was, uh,
someone else brought up global warming
and the kid goes, it's a natural cycle.
It's always habits and natural
cycle. I go, you're not a scientist.
I go, you're a scientist.
You know, scientists show me
your phd. You're a scientist.
You're not a scientist. Right. I
started mocking him. I go, listen, man,
you're being silly. You don't know
what the fuck you're talking about.
Where'd you and where'd you get it?
Just tell me where you got that mindset.
Where did it come from? It's that no
nonsense, right wing mentality. Yeah.
They don't even question it.
It's clearly what's really fascinating
about it is that they're always
supporting big business,
but yet no one gets fucked over
more than blue collar folks.
When it comes to big business, no one
gets fucked over. When we start that too.
It's like some,
sometimes this outlook is actually the
one that's most injurious to you in a way
of of your own life and your own sort
of happiness in a way. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
And I mean you,
if you think about it,
the people that are less educated for the
most part or more likely to work for a
company or need a company to employ them,
those are more likely people that
are going to get lower paying jobs.
Those are more likely people that
are going to need some form of public
assistance or the possible,
but yet those are the people that
have this pull yourself up by your own
bootstraps mentality and that the,
these fucking welfare rats,
they have all these crazy
ideas in their head.
Whereas the educated people who are
more likely to be able to fend for
themselves or more likely at least to
have the possibility to have a higher
paying job because of the
fact they're educated,
at least in theory or more
likely to support public
assistance or more likely to
be against some of the environmentally
destroying policies. Yeah.
Of of big businesses. It's real weird
how people just sort of form these,
these patterns that they lock into that,
as you said,
can be really against their
own self interest and self
benefit going forward. Um,
but I don't know about you,
but I found like as I've gotten older,
like when I was in school,
I was a total like lip,
like almost as left as you could go,
as PC as you could go.
And as I get older I feel like I come,
I come to some sort of, not the
center, I'll always be to the left,
but you know what I mean? There's, there's
certain things about liberal, you know,
they get on my nerves as well.
Like, I mean, and that's just,
I feel like any fully rounded human being,
it's not going to always be in one
camp that's higher. Lee, you know,
the approach.
I think I'm very much a conglomeration
of liberal and conservative ideas.
I found like more and more, well,
there's an old saying, show me,
I'm a young man who, uh, show me.
I'm a young man who is not liberal
and I'll show you a man with no heart.
Show me an old man is not conservative
and I'll show you a man with no brain.
And it's that somewhere along the line
you realize that people need a certain
amount of difficulty in life.
They need a certain amount of hardship
and they need a certain amount of,
they need obstacles and needed
to overcome those obstacles.
And when you set it up so that they
never have to overcome obstacles,
and you give them a consistent
series of safety nets, they get lazy.
And that is true.
And that doesn't mean that all people
on welfare are lazy or that welfare is
only for the lazy.
That's ridiculous as well.
But there's some lazy fucking people out
there and not just lazy, Lazy Thinkers.
There's just,
there's a lot of weakness.
And when you give people
the lottery ticket, you know
what happens? They fucking,
they lose all their money
and they fall apart.
It's just people need
to accomplish things.
It's a part of the whole genetic sequence
that has been sort of ingrained in the
human species from all
of our past behaviors.
I mean all of our human reward systems
of accomplishing things and feeling good
about accomplishing things and building
up self confidence. And that's real,
you know, so the, the pull yourself
by your bootstraps in a lot of ways.
That's good advice.
Yeah.
Unfortunately it gets conglomerated
and attached to this hatred towards
homosexuals. It's weird, you
know, fucking pro war stance,
strong religion,
religious kind of a context
and flavor to things as well,
which kind of has a, you talk about
things happening when you're a kid.
I've always felt that, you know,
that's one of the things that,
that really influences your thinking and
the way that you have an outlook on the
world. It's, and it's,
I think that's a part of what religion
does is they want to get your young and
they want to get you indoctrinated
and they want to sort of have a,
a good soldier for the, for the balance
going forward kind of a thing. Um,
and that, that was, I never grew up that
way. I don't know about you, but like I,
we're,
we're not a very religious household,
but I've certainly come across a lot
of religion and some of whom are like
totally awesome and really nice
and really, you know, I, I, my,
my wife actually came up really baptist
and there was some point like around
when she was 18 or 19, it's just
like, I can't do this anymore.
I'm tired of feeling bad
about myself for Xyz. Um,
you know,
and so she sort of left the fold,
but she said that was one of the
most difficult thing she ever did,
peeling away from really all of her
friends, all of, all of that, you know,
because of the entire, it was a nice
little safe bubble that she was in. And,
and she, she still likes a lot
of those people to this day. Um,
but overall it was something she felt
she had to do in order to sort of grow,
I guess, or, or, or make some sort of
separation from that time in her life.
Well,
there's a disconnect if you,
if you subscribe to religion and all
of its principles by the book you,
this is just a massive disconnect you
have to have with just reality itself.
You're believing in Adam and eve and
resurrections and miracles and no evidence
whatsoever to support any of these
things that are completely contrary to
anything that you've ever experienced.
And then all the evidence that
you see of Science, oh earth,
there's only 6,000 years old
according to this book. Oh, okay.
Did they just find some hundred million
year old shit lies propaganda by the
liberal media? They were planted down
there by the, you know, by Barack? Yeah.
Well you know the homosexuals.
Yeah,
there's all have,
you know,
and they went down and they buried those
bones and they sort of acid dated them
somehow so that they
seem older than they are.
We know carbon dating. It's not an
exact sign. No. Fracking is a myth,
you know?
Meanwhile though,
they'll talk bad about homosexuals while
they're eating a shrimp cocktail and
you're like, Yo, dude,
you got to read the whole book because
there's more shit about not eating
shellfish. Then there is
about being gay. You know,
you're not supposed to eat shrimp
and not supposed to eat pigs.
Like there's a lot of shit that you're
doing wrong and that's supposed to work
on Saturday. That's right. Yeah. You're
not supposed to have religious tattoos.
You fuck head like that. So fuck yeah.
You're not supposed to tattoo your body.
That's in the Bible. People have
religious tattoos. It's like,
talk about not reading the whole book.
Yeah. Oh, exactly. I think, and
you just pick and choose. Sure.
One of the funniest things is, you know,
really hardcore, uh, Christians will,
will make fun of Scientology,
which, fair enough? Go ahead.
I'm perfectly fine if you want
to make fun of Scientology, but,
but to obligate their own kind
of weird stories than that.
Their book presents as
well. It's like, yeah, it's,
there's a certain you are you not spotting
the irony here that there's a certain
similarity between their weird Phaeton
run sort of stories and your weird,
you know, died and reborn after three
days. Kind of an all of the sort of,
you know, stories that, that we
will sort of beggar reality as well.
Well I think compartmentalize thinking
is very dangerous and I think once you
just sort of make your mind up that
your way is the only way you stop being
objective and you cease
all introspective thought.
You get sort of locked into this
mindset and you put these blinders on,
they don't allow you see you,
you,
you just see yourself as
how ridiculous you are.
And that's how people get caught
doing dumb shit. Like Ted Haggardy,
the guy who was, oh God damn
running this giant religious church,
huge stadium filled with people.
That's right.
Meanwhile Smoking Crystal Meth,
Bang and gay prostitutes.
And there's this recent guy who was anti
gay marriage proponent who turns out he
had run a,
a a female drag strip show
homeboy's named Jamie.
This guy, it just came out the other
day, was in North Carolina, um,
politician and he was a fucking,
he's a drag queen and he hates guessing.
You see that there was that other one
recently where that KKK guy shot and then
they find out he'd had sex
with a male prostitute,
black male prostitute dressed as a woman.
Or
it doesn't take long before you've
somehow dig into these guys' history and
you're like, I, it's not even
surprising anymore really.
It's like I knew that little
skeleton was in your cousin Craig.
See that's the liberal media.
Just this man is in jail,
talk for himself. So the man's in
jail and they sell that information.
Just now have the information that he
has sex with a gay male prostitute.
How about where,
where were you a year ago?
Do you know how easy it is to doctor
macro fish so that they could go back and
look through it and it would be,
they're pretty easy. Pretty so,
so they're watching what you're
doing right now. Here's homeboy.
That's what he used to look like.
Oh really? His name's Steve Wilde.
Just just,
just a rough number of Cox in his mouth.
How many sets do you say
that a thousand lifetime?
I would say that probably
is a look at them.
That's what face you just
want to fuck big fat.
Chubby cheeks probably knows
how to take a tick like a champ,
especially when he's got the earrings on.
Those are just handles big grips,
big grippy earrings. Look at them.
Silly Bitch Domini in the, by the way,
is nothing wrong with
dressing like a woman.
Nothing wrong with stuck in a thousand
cars. You're sort of, when you're,
when you espouse a certain viewpoint
that's totally against all of that,
you know,
and it's really mean spirited and
hateful towards that kind of a thing that
really gets on your nerves.
Yeah. It's ridiculous. Yeah,
but people love to do that.
They love to point the finger.
It's like no one loves to criticize women
for being promiscuous more than sluts,
sluts, love to shit on other
slots. Is that so? Oh good,
good Mowgli. Nick Carter,
Aka Craig. They do, man.
It's like a big thing with girls there.
The girls who are promiscuous love to
shit on other girls who are promiscuous.
They, oh is that fucking bitch? She's
a whore. She's a fucking everybody.
Meanwhile you're fucking everybody
you know and men do the same thing.
Guys who sleep around are constantly
shitting on guys who slipped her sleep or
had too much worse.
It's a common thing.
It's like people try to throw people
off the case like, oh it's like, yeah,
exactly. It's like that self hatred thing
almost sometimes that that sorta like,
yeah,
there's definitely a lot of that.
You know used to see that about a guys
who used to steal jokes with sometimes
like accuse other people stealing their
Joe throw him off the case and other
comedians would be like,
is this motherfucking serious?
Like everybody knows you steal,
you do on
stage.
And mitzia would constantly accuse people
of stealing as material because he was
the biggest and everybody would be like,
what the F is going on here?
But when you think about like the
most obvious defense, that's the one.
If I'm getting accused of something,
I'll just,
I'll just accuse other people of the
same thing that I'm running up into.
I was wondering that too,
like for you,
you know I talked about earlier about
like when I rate read Stephen King the
second time as an adult, as
a writer myself and trying
to break it apart. Do you,
do you do that with other comedians?
Do you like we'll listen to them the first
time and just like fuck that. So good.
And then the second time you
sort of try and look at their,
just see what they're doing. Not to,
not to copy it or steal anything,
but just see how,
how are,
how are they forensically almost putting
together these jokes and how were they
sort of,
what I really do is I like to go back
and listen to really old stuff to try to
understand the time period.
Cause I think that a lot of comedy is a
weird thing. Like a lot of old movies,
they,
they still hold up today.
Like if you go back and watch the hustler
with Jack, such a good movie. Yeah, yeah.
Great movie. Yeah. Paul knew
holds up completely today.
It's still a great movie.
But any comedy from 1962
very tough to listen.
Yeah, it's changed. It's
comedy changes so fast.
I think like some like horror or
or something like the hustler,
like the thing is as good now,
you know,
the Kirk Russell one as as it
was when it was made, but comedy,
there's a certain shelf life,
it evolves a lot faster I think.
And something that was really edgy at
one point becomes stale dated. I think.
Yeah, that's, that's sort of my
feeling about guys like Lenny Bruce,
who in my opinion is probably
the most important comedian ever.
And he was the guy who got arrested the
most and he was the guy who pushed the
boundaries of understanding language and
content and what's the intent of what
you're trying to say and what do you,
what,
what are we doing when we're suppressing
this intent? And he was a brilliant,
brilliant guy who went,
ultimately went mad.
I never followed him towards the end of
it. Oh yeah. He died of a heroin overdose.
He,
uh,
he went mad and he would go on stage
and just read transcripts of his legal
proceedings. I mean, it was, it
was really, really boring stuff.
Kauffman NASC kind of, no, no, no, no.
Because Kauffman was doing it ironically,
like he would stand on stage and play
mighty mouse theme song, go here,
I come to save the day and he would just
freak people out because they expected
him to do common and it would
just do weird shit. Yeah.
But Lenny was going nuts and
towards the end of his life, um,
he would go on stage and read directly
out of the transcripts and try to explain
why the judge was wrong.
But there was no humor really.
Just more like it was going crazy. Yeah.
And he was doing heroin all the time.
It means there's a lot
going on. Yeah. Yeah.
But I will listen to his comedy and try
to put myself into this sort of almost
innocent mindset of the people that
were listed are living in the 1960s
listening to this kind of comedy.
Trying to wrap my head around what kind
of an impact this guy would, would have
had,
but I don't necessarily try
to deconstruct their comedy.
Comedy is different in a
lot of ways than fiction.
And I think in fiction when
you're reading a great novel,
like you're reading Moby
Dick or something like that,
it still holds true holds the test of
time. Yeah. When you, you, you read that,
you can kind of get a feeling for the
way the narrative is driven and the way
the, the use of words shapes the
environment that you're imagining.
And comedy is very different in
that. It's just, um, I guess I,
I certainly did when I was
first starting out, but I,
but I don't really do that anymore.
If I watch comedy now,
I watch it just to enjoy it.
Yeah. Try to watch it as a fan.
Yeah. Yeah. And I do, I mean, I do
the same thing with, with reading, uh,
and there's some stuff that you realize,
this is awesome.
This is outside of what I do,
I could possibly do anyways.
I imagine that you listened to
some comedians and it's the same.
It's like what they're doing is,
it's fabulous,
but it's so far field from the star.
It allows you to actually just to enjoy
it totally as a fan because there's no
worry about, wow, this is
going to influence me. Uh,
in some way that that would
be problematical. Sure.
Cause it's just so different.
But who's an example like that for you
as a writer is just so, so different?
Yeah. Um, well like, yeah,
like, like Margaret Atwood,
for example,
the Canadian writer,
she did like the Handmaid's
tale was made into a movie.
I don't remember that
you vomit or something.
If someone knows to run with me,
sorry.
Go ahead and want to do a week in prison
or read the Handmaid's tale of the
Margaret Atwood book.
No,
you read one a week for the rest
of your life. Like I'll do my week.
I'd lie rather take the prison term.
I'll tell you my presence,
but you don't understand it's going to
enrich you and grow you as a person. Oh,
okay. Yeah. I've come on, not the kind
of person I want to grow to be, you know?
Right.
Take a fucking a pineapple tree
and you grow it in the same
where you grow grapes. Right? It's
not the same environment. You fuck it.
I don't know if that's a good analogy.
I, you know, I worry about that too.
Cause I'm, I am a little bit of a
chameleon. So if I start reading too many,
say like newer books, suddenly that
becomes, or Westerns, you know,
I think I wanted,
my next book wants to be sort of like a,
like a horror western sort of
a thing. So first of all, you,
I need to read a lot of those
things just to situate myself,
I think in that time.
And you sort of get the feel for it,
but you do worry that you're going
to be like, you know, you want it,
don't want to be derivative. I
guess that's the thing. Right? And,
and that and that, you know, because
in, in, in comedy it's joke stealing,
but it's all plagiarism. It's the
same thing. And there's, there's,
there's some writers who probably get
too close to their source material and
then they find out later that like,
this is so close that it's
almost copying what this,
this other person is who I really
admire. I see why I did it, but fuck,
I'm not own self here.
I'm more
like just this person.
Yeah. That's very common
in comedy in the beginning.
Yeah. Where you're looking for
your voice, right. Your style.
Like eventually I feel
it's like a thumbprint and
initially your thumb print is,
it's,
there's nothing on it,
but slowly the world's start
developing and you get something that's
distinctively your own
when it comes with time,
don't really know what you're doing yet.
And you want to be like
this guy that you admire.
So you start doing colony
that's similar to this guy.
For me on the beginning it was
Richard. Jenny course. Yeah.
In the mask.
I remember him in the one,
one of his one movie wants to stand up
was so much better than his movie stuff,
but I remember,
uh,
like being a big admirer of his and
then onstage like hearing myself going,
Oh my God, I'm like, I'm
ripping off his clothes.
There's so many guys who they start
out like, I mean, this is like,
I was essentially an open miker I was
like a year into my comedy career or
somewhere around there. And uh, I
realized it, but I see it all the time.
There's a lot of,
like,
there's a lot of David tell clones out
there and there was a few dean cook
clones for a while and there's
probably some Louis CK clay now. Yeah,
yeah.
Let me,
is this just a thing where someone admires
his style of comedy and they start to
imitate? I've, I've seen my own act
onstage as in someone else's mouth.
It's got to feel weird, weird, parsing it
out. You're sort of like, that is, yeah.
And it's not, it's not necessarily the
actual, uh, joke that they've taken,
but they've taken more your,
you know what I mean?
You're starting at the essence
of the way that you present it,
what way you deliver things.
Also like your subject matter,
they'll just twist around
your subject matter.
And so it's not like your material
they're taking, but God damn, it's close.
It's just like you,
he can see the road that got them there.
That's only a couple of blocks away
from the source. Yeah. And you can't,
you can't really claim
originality cause the,
the real problem with originality is
there's no such thing because everybody,
yeah. And that's, you know, publishers
want that. They're like, what? What is,
it's like everything's been done already.
I hate unique viewpoints.
They can be unique but
ultimately original boy,
the whole language is an original. What
if you're going to write about murder,
monsters, air, water,
the elements. I mean,
all those things have
been covered and done.
We all understand that any description
that you have of any of these various
aspects is going to resonate with
people because they directly have either
literary experience in it,
some film experience,
and then have an actual
real life experience. Yeah.
So there is no real truly
original thought anymore. Oh,
but I found, I don't
know about you with, uh,
with comedy or with some of
the other things you've done,
but one of the biggest leaps I made is
recognizing that my own life is, um,
has value. You know what I mean? There
are interesting moments in my life,
interesting scenes, things that I've
experienced and you bring them in,
in the service of a character.
It's, you know, it's,
it's transported and you're telling it
through, through a character's eyes.
And I've always felt like there,
you don't have to make anything up,
right. You're just going back and
remembering as deeply as possible.
And those things are original.
Even if it's within a story that it's,
it's self might've been
told a thousand times.
The one thing that you can go
back and you can stake a claim on.
It's like this comes from
some element of my own life.
And I know it has to be original.
Not mean even that's not original because
other human beings have experienced it.
And that's your hope is that you're
actually going to be able to reach into
their chest and really sort of have
some sort of reckoning between you.
So I'm sorta like synchronicity that
you meet, maybe. Hopefully, you know,
do I think the word isn't original?
The real,
the real word is derivative.
And the real problem that people have
is when they're intentionally derivative
and that what that does is
it stifles creativity. Yeah.
Because someone like say,
say if someone, I don't want to give
away the story, the of your book,
the troop. But if someone read your
book and decided, you know what,
I'm going to make my own story
about this exact scenario.
And then they kept going back to your
book and they started adding elements to
it with different dialogue,
but the same elements and you know,
and here's the fucking guy was,
I mean that's, that's gross.
And it upsets us when we find out
that your originality, we will,
we can see you have to be or perceived
to be originality is really just you
comping and twisting around the
original work of someone else.
It's very upsetting. Yeah. Oh yeah.
Yeah. And you feel like that's again,
why would you get into it in
the first place? You know, I,
but I know in publishing, say when
the Da Vinci Code came out, you know,
publishers were like, we need the
next Davinci code. And there would be,
there were a lot of uh,
sort of knock knockoffs of it with
the same kind of ideas and, and,
but they were actually,
you know,
the writers whether they wanted to write
them or not. Sometimes money, you know,
how has an influence there,
you know,
if someone's going to offer
you a nice amount of money to,
to write what you know is sort of a, a
bit of a knock off, um, you know, uh,
people, people may be enticed
into sort of doing that. You know,
whether that's why they got
into writing in the first place.
You have to assume not,
you know. Um, but uh,
uh, yeah, I found like there's this,
there's some element of that and there's,
there's some element of, um, you know,
our original publishers sort of
don't want originality sometimes.
Sometimes they're like, this is a known
commodity. This is working really well.
We would like you to do stuff
like, like this, you know?
And sometimes they're even scared of
original. I was like, Lenny Bruce,
I people who, who are that original,
they, it's not an easy road to hoe.
Whereas if you do sort of do maybe
a rip off of a Dane Cook Act,
I think you might get initially get a
better pop than you would if you're really
charting sorta really
original territory ends.
It depends on how well you're doing
it for an idiot and you're ripping off
someone like, yeah, you
might get a little reaction.
This is a few of those
guys out there right now,
but I think that what we appreciate
in someone is we appreciate artistic
expression,
meaning
that we're all influenced by music and
movies and literature and things that
we've experienced in life. There's
influences that are just undeniable,
but what is your intent when you
sit down to create something,
is your intent to express yourself
in you in your own unique language,
your own unique experiences
in your own creativity?
Or are you just copying shit?
Yeah,
when you're just copying shit that
makes us angry. Yeah, of course.
There's like a certain amount of
like hate that Nickelback gets yes.
That I'm not sure why they get that hate,
but I think that some of it has to do
with the fact that it seems like they
concocted it.
Like they went and put together
these songs based on some algorithm.
Yeah. Yeah. I don't know if
it's fair. I don't get it.
I don't know why the hate exist,
but boy,
if you want to fucking
make an audience laugh,
just talk about how Shitty
Nickelback is and people go, yeah,
they do suck.
But there's certain bands that probably
suck equally or worse that take,
get a free pass or suck in a total.
Yeah,
different way. I think what bothers
me, Mumford and sons, I said it.
Yeah. Even, I mean, I hate to
throw these guys under the bus,
but arcade fire a little bit.
Oh you don't know how they're Canadian
Canadian band and it's like there,
you know it's like if you're
being like super original,
that's almost in a way as a
fake originality, you know
what I mean? Like I've,
I've noticed that as well is like you're
not really as original as you think you
are,
but you've convinced other people that
you're really original and that's like a
double delusion.
Whereas Nickelback is what they are.
Well it's when someone's affected what
I get about Mumford and sons, I like,
I like a lot of their songs.
I think some of their songs are very good,
especially the early songs.
But now I feel like they're in this
groove of doing that certain kind of music
and so they dress a certain kind of way
and I'm like, you're wearing a costume.
You might as well be dressed
up as a fucking clown. Okay.
Cause you're dressed up like a guy.
You look like a pioneer or something.
You're out there with a
mason jar in your hand.
You're playing a fucking homemade fiddle
for what are you doing dude? Yeah, no,
in the middle of the field. Yeah. What's
up wheat field and the fucking piano?
What's going on here? You're,
you're, you're, you're,
this is an affectations and
you wonder if they started
that way or if they got
engineered like someone, some,
some producer came and said, listen,
we need more wheat fields. We unique.
I look at all these guys in jars
saying what the fuck is going on now?
Whether they started that way or whether
that's what's up with those boots.
Hoedown boots going on.
You
are you working in the field and then
you took some time off to sing or you a
multimillionaire rock star cause I
get confused. What's your fucking,
you're goofy beard. Fucking stop. Dot.
What's up with the fake trees behind
you too? That's even more offensive.
We're down home.
We're country.
It's not a fucking hotel lobby and Beverly
Hills doing a photo shoot with makeup
on. Fuck yourself. Well, I think
that, you know, you become a,
you also become a prisoner to your success
if you get a amount of success doing
a certain thing. Like I was talking
about this yesterday, but I,
I had a friend who was a fat guy who was
the agent told him don't lose weight.
You lose weight, you're
losing roles. Yeah.
Like he's like you're losing parts if you,
if you,
if you lose weight and like he is just,
he was trapped in this thing that
he had created this overweight
boring character. Exactly. Well
the, and that does seem to be like,
I'm sure you've talked about it before,
but like it's not as funny.
Like Joe Piscopo even getting ripped, you
know what I mean? You managed to do it,
but Joe Piscopo couldn't go from the sort
of weedy guy to like the big bulky guy
of like dead heat and maintain
being as funny as as he was.
And the same thing with fat.
If you lose the weight,
suddenly people are just like, oh,
you're not as funny. And why is that?
I'm not really sure. But there's the
physical comedy of just being a big guy.
Yeah.
I Dunno what happened with Joe Piscopo,
but I've heard the comparisons of you.
Oh really? Anna, you don't welcome it.
I imagine I don't give a fuck.
It doesn't bother. I did.
Maybe that's why it didn't work because
I didn't give a fuck if I get it.
Plus you came on the scene,
you were already big. Yeah.
You never understood is in some
other body position. You know,
you're always a big guy.
Back News
radio when I first saw you, so it wasn't
as big. I didn't really lift this,
which words back then?
I was just kickboxing,
but I had been a black belt in martial
arts since I was 17 so I had come from
this physical background from the
beginning where I, I kinda was really,
I'm self conscious about it.
When I first used to do comedy,
it would like kind of hide my
body a little. Oh really? Yeah.
We're like really bulky clothes to sort
of hide the my shape because I felt like
people wouldn't understand that.
I had seen guys on stage who were
muscular too and it'd be like well that's
really abstract going over is not smart
to like come up and like sort of a
ripped up or whatever. Really
Sean. Yeah they don't want,
people don't want to see that they would
do, they'd rather see you out of shape.
That's kind of funny to have gone go stage
with a big beer gut slapping your gut
while you're telling your punch line.
It's kind of funny but it doesn't mean
that you can't be funny and be fit.
It's like we have these ideas that
we know what's funny and what's not.
But you don't know until you see it.
And that's one of the reasons why someone
can't really teach you how to be funny
cause you could never teach Mitch Hedberg
like you never have a class in how to
be Mitch Hedberg. No, cause
it doesn't fit any rules. No.
He's his own entity entirely.
Yeah.
So you can't fit Joey Diaz. There's
gear, there's guys, you just,
you can't fit them into a mold.
It doesn't.
And then you realized somewhere
along the line, if it's funny to you,
it's about trying to figure out a way to
get inside people's heads and get them
to relate. They can relate. Yeah,
but it has to be funny. Do you,
and what's a lot of bad comedy is it's
not even funny to them. They're just you.
There's, there's a certain
stage of comedy. There's
two stages in the beginning.
The one stage number one is you
just do anything that works.
You just, they're like, there's like
hammers and saws and you just using tools,
which joke,
it's like a tool.
Once you get a certain
amount of proficiency and
confidence and certain amount
of stage time,
then you start doing things that you
think are funny and then that's the shift,
the shift. It goes from doing
things that you think will work.
And then I started and you look around
and they laugh and you're like, oh,
thank God. And then two, you get a guy who
goes on stage with like a half a grand.
He's like, why is this going on? Because
I see that. I'm like, Whoa, fuck.
Are you talking and the
audience starts laughing. Yes.
Because they relate to the
way this guy's thinking is,
he actually does see humor in what he's
saying. It's an honest vision of humor.
Yeah. And those two stages are very
distinct and there's a huge difference.
And that's the thing about joke thieves
and people who are derivative is they
never get out of that first stage,
even though as positive as they can get.
That's why the,
there's a lot of guys who started out
stealing jokes and then they stopped.
I could name names,
I will not.
But they stopped stealing and they started
writing original material and their
original material is dog shit.
And the reason why is they never
really learned how to do comedy.
They never really understand the language
of comedy because a big part of comedy
has to deal with honesty, both honesty
with the environment that you live in,
an honesty with yourself and how you
interface with all the people around you.
And if you're pretending you this comedic
genius, I'm really just a plagiarist.
You're fucking,
you're dealing with a lot of demons.
You're dealing with a lot of walls
you've built up in your psyche and those
walls just trip you up when you
try to write original stuff.
I would imagine that's the
same way with literature
very much, very much. And I think
that second stage, uh, is, is right.
The first stage is your
sort of, uh, you're,
you're almost emulating the
people that you love, you know,
and the second stage is you want
to do something on your own.
And that second stage I think with you
is dealing with the idea that you're
confident enough that this joke means a
lot to me. Whether it's going to go over,
I can actually deal with that.
Whereas in the first stage you couldn't
possibly deal with the reaction that
didn't feed some sort of
sense of accomplishment or
get them to laugh or that I
think sometimes with, with comedians
that I've watched, obviously I don't,
I rarely, rarely watched them through
the early stages of their career,
but they're there, the comfortability
there, and it's the same with writers.
They're like, if I fail, that's fine.
I wanted to fail doing something really
interesting, really original to me.
And that really is an expression of what
the hell I got into this in the first
place for
a good example of that is
a hunter Thompson in the
early days used to take f f
Scott Fitzgerald and just
retyping Oh yeah, he would,
he would retire the great Gatsby
over and over and over again.
And the idea was that I think he
did it with Hemingway's well. Okay.
And the idea was that he was learning the
rhythm of great writing and that there
was in, in writing down the
great writing of other people,
you sort of develop a sense of the rhythm.
Yeah, I could see that. And in a way,
that's how I got into comedy because
I would like see like an HBO special.
And then I would tell my friends, Holy
Shit, did you see Sam Kinison last night?
He had this joke.
And then I would tell them the joke and
they would laugh at me telling them the
joke and I would sort of realize
through rhythm of doing Sam's material,
you know, in his voice, you know, and
I was married for two fucking years.
Oh Wow.
How about like club bed and your friends
are laughing and you kind of get the
rhythm of this,
this thing which is very similar to what
what learner did. Yeah, absolutely.
Did you ever do that?
Did you ever try to like picture yourself
writing a great piece that someone
else had written and just like go over it?
I did a lot of, um, not quite like
that, but similarly like you'd,
you'd read a,
there are some writers probably the same
as some comedians who style seems so
easy to imitate. It was an example.
Well Ray Carver, the short story writer,
the American short story writer would be
an example of a style that you look at
and you're like, I could do
this, but you can't. Once you,
once you really set your mind to like,
I'll try and write a carver type story.
That's what makes the genius there
I think is that it seems easy.
It seems that something you can do,
but,
but the genius is not only in the
genius of him but in the genius of his
deceptively simple style.
So I tried to write say a carver story
and it was a total nightmare and a
failure. Um, you know, we have things
in the writing recom trunk stories,
basically stories that you write,
you throw him in a trunk,
you're never going to see him again.
And my trunk is full of stories like that.
And I imagine your, your trunk
similarly, it's full of stuff.
And these are all things that like
you need to go through. I mean, I, I,
I probably was rejected 200 times at
magazines before I finally placed a story.
Like I could literally have
filled a shopping bag or a
pillowcase with rejection
slips.
When you have an idea for a story,
how many of those ideas actually wound
up being wind up being stories that you
will turn into a book or a
short story? Well, it's a,
it's a pretty small percentage. Uh,
in terms of the ones that you know,
I always think of, it's like a, you
know, the way a pearl gets created,
you've got like an oyster and us,
a little bit of sand gets in it and
then if enough like Nacro whatever goes
around it, then I'm like,
okay, that's enough.
It feels like the characters
are strong enough.
I've got an idea of the plot and
where I want to send these characters.
Then you sort of harvest that
pearl and it becomes a short story,
becomes a novel, but there's
several that just are imperfect.
You can tell just in their conception
they're imperfect. I don't have it.
You know, it's different, right? I see.
I would write a store, I'd send it out.
If it's not working,
you don't really know until you get
enough rejections that it's clearly, okay,
that's this fucking thing ain't working.
Do you guys get up on stage?
That's the different,
or like have you ever,
how many times do you tell a joke that
you really feel strong about or work on a
piece of material before
you have to say this,
this isn't meeting my expectation of what
I thought or do you just keep telling
it anyway and just say fuck it.
This is
the depends.
Depends on how much I really enjoy it.
There's certain ones just fucking
never work and I do. I'm just for,
there's certain ones
that are right and I go,
I know this has got something but
I can't figure out what it is.
And then there's certain,
there's certain bits that as I write them,
they come out and fully finished
form. Yeah. Oh that's brilliant.
One that happened.
I got one of my favorite bits and I'm
doing right now that is in the moment.
I wrote it on a plane and I wrote it.
It's like a 10 minute piece and I wrote
it in its full form on a plane and I did
it on stage that Monday and
it just destroyed. It was,
it was like, it was done. Like
from the minute it came out,
it came out in June and it was,
it resonated with me and I was so
angry when I wrote it and it was so,
it was the,
it was a about a certain particular
group of people that are so incredibly
hypocritical and ridiculous that it was
due and I'd caught someone lying about
something and it was in this
group of people and I was like,
I have had enough of this and I just
went on and married came out like as a
chunk it was done. Then there's other
bits, like I know there's something there,
but I don't know what it is.
Yeah. And sometimes they,
those bits will last for years and I'll
throw them in like every third or fourth
set. When I'm killing in the middle,
I'll throw it in there and that'll just,
the audience be like, what the fuck is
that? I'm like, all right, you got it.
It's got to die.
Yeah.
Sometimes it's like you feel the energy
of the room and maybe I can slip this in.
And it's, I mean with me too,
I think it's a matter of,
I've had some stories that constantly
got rejected and then you, you,
I think you get a bit of a
name for yourself and then
those will find acceptance
because they're like, okay, well he's
done this and this and this. But then,
but I find to me like speed is something
like I wrote the true probably in about
six weeks, which is the fastest I've
ever written anything. But it was fun.
You know,
I'd come out of wherever the room
where I write in my wife would be like,
you look energized.
You don't look like all the dragon
haggard like you do when you stumble out
after working on your other books.
Like a vampire has been stuck
in your blood out for eight
hours. Um, and I'm like,
that's sort of what has told me that I
hope I am able to write a lot more books
in the horror genre because I just enjoy
the writing of it. It's more fun to me.
It's more, it comes like that. And I mean,
the reason I think that came
to you so fast, first of all,
because you're passionate about it,
but second of all,
because you've been working at it a
long time and when those things come,
you know how to deal with them. And
I think now I know better. Okay,
if the idea comes to me and it's, I'm,
I'm ready to make, make hay with it.
Well I think you should really
read a lot more harm man.
But just because of what you said and
because of the book being really fun.
I love that as that genre.
And I love when a book
like that comes out.
And so you saying that like this is
something that like thrilled you and
energize you as your rent. I really
hope you keep doing that, man.
Not, yeah, no, I appreciate
it. Thank you. And I'm, we're,
we're sort of in between contracts
right now. So I don't know. I might be,
you know, selling oranges on the side of
the freeway for all that. I know. When,
when, when I next w when I next see you,
I see you come to Massey Hall right?
I will,
I'll have to come out.
I saw you were at Massey Hall once in
Toronto in a couple of times and the Sony
Centre reisling go and check
that out. But anyways, we're,
we're sort of in that weird space where
I don't really know what's going to
happen. Exactly. So, so hopefully
I'll have good news. Listen man,
you could self publish. This
is a new era. It's true. Yeah.
There is a lot more of that going on.
Some huge successful
people doing it that way.
Unbelievable success.
People have had unknown's that have put
out something and just through word of
mouth through Amazon and
what have you and your books.
It's incredible, isn't it? Gaps
in publishers who, who you wonder,
like I read this book wool by a writer
called Hugh Howey and it's Sorta Saifai
really, really damn good.
And your end, you know,
you find out his history as he's been
rejected by x number of publishers and
you're like, how did that happen? You know
what I mean? But it does. It does happen.
And it's great that there's that
opportunity now that like, okay,
well listen that, that's fine. I get it.
You guys have whatever
agenda that you're pursuing.
This is what I want to write and
I have a way to get it out to my,
my hopefully readership and
build it that way. Now is this,
is this book the truth? Is it out now?
Uh, yeah. Yeah. When did you come out?
You got an arc of it? Yeah. It came out
a couple months ago. Yeah, there it is.
There's a new cover too.
They just,
they totally changed the cover
while they changed the Koa. Darker.
It's just something that they do
in publishing from time to time.
I'm not sure why either. But yeah,
they made a big, a big change of it.
So now it's just an isolated guy
on a hilltop or something. Well,
I got the best one I liked.
I liked that one too with the,
that's the, uh, the UK cover. It
looks that way. Yeah. With the, the,
the birds and the lightening
flashes. I like it. Yeah.
I like the American cover, but yeah,
it's totally, totally different for sure.
Have you started writing a new one?
Yeah,
the followup is we did do that one for
sure. It's called the deep, so it takes,
I love undersea stuff and like I love
like the ocean so it takes place at the
bottom of the Mariana.
You know when a James Cameron went
down in that so eight miles below the
surface. Crazy fuck he is. I know
he's a nut. He's out of his mind.
He is out of his mind a millions of
dollars to the bottom of the ocean fucking
boat. Yeah. And just, you know, picks up
what, there's nothing down there either.
The first God ever do that too. He
is. He is. And I don't know if you,
I don't know about you.
Like claustrophobia is one thing that
I'm not good but in tight spaces and if
you saw what he went down in, it
was basically like he had, you know,
metal down this side of this side. He
basically went down in a coffin. Yeah.
I don't have a problem with tight spaces.
I do have a problem with tight spaces
at the bottom of the notion though,
how many miles deepest? Well challenger
deep is, is below the Marianas trench.
So that's eight miles.
And the pressure is something like seven
jumbo jets per like pressing down on
your per square foot. So
yeah, it's, I feel like that.
See, I don't know about you. What are
you scared of? That's interesting.
Are you yeah,
like animals,
animals I find with a kid now I'm
afraid of shit happened into my,
my soul for something. That's
thing, but it's the Marriott,
look at this image of that Jamie
just pulled there it is. She's,
so there's Mount Everest.
That's the height of Mount
Everest compared to the deep,
the deepness of challenging.
So yeah, that's insane. It is.
Miles miles down. That's the deepest
part of the ocean that we're aware of.
Is that what it is that we're aware of?
There might be a spot somewhere that they
haven't other could very well be. Yeah,
exactly. But um, that's
the deepest known depth.
Damn deep.
Yeah. That is so ridiculous.
But I figured, okay,
well I don't like tight spaces.
I don't like that pressure.
I don't like the dark like down there
darknesses I mean I don't think it's like
the darkness between the stars.
It's that dark.
It's probably a darkness that I don't
know if I've ever grappled with. So yeah,
for a horror book it sort of has a lot
of potential of things that scare the
shit out of me. And that's sort
of where I got to start with.
Is it like a monster book? No, no, no.
It's a ghost.
So they're billing it as sort of
like the abyss meets the shining.
So there is kind of that that you
know, the, the shining being like, oh,
it's almost like a haunted,
they've set up a research station down
there and it's another crew going down to
figure out what the hell happened to the
crew beforehand. I could have read it.
Yeah. Yeah. So, so I'm done.
It's all done. It's all done.
Yes. I will make sure you get a priority.
Uh, when the art comes out I'll,
I'll get one shipped. When do you think
it will be done? Well, I don't know.
I feel like they probably are going
to do a few. If soon they're there,
they're put there. It's
every, it's the year after.
So basically it's January of next
year, but you'll, the arcs will be out,
you know. But do they, when
you do something like that,
like do you bring it to the publisher
and the publisher gives notes?
Yes. Yeah. Um, basically you,
I got a two book contract,
so I had already written the troop,
gave it to my agent.
My agent sent it into the publisher.
They accepted, they say, well,
we want another book too. What's
your idea? I said, and on something,
something to do with down in the
ocean. They said, good. Sold.
So you write that one and then you
just send it to your editor and he,
in this case, yeah, it gave me all
sorts of notes and uh, you know,
you work on that and you go back and
forth and then eventually at some point we
say, we're fucking sick of
this. Are we done? Yes, we're
done. So That's interesting.
No, who's qualified to give you
notes like that? Like, how do,
how do you distinguish whether or not
someone's qualified to give you notes?
And do you often disagree
with their notes?
Yes. Cause you wouldn't, I guess you
wouldn't have that really. I mean,
you might have trusted people
that you would deal with and say,
well what do you think of this bit? You
know, so don't even do that. No, no, no.
The audience does it. Ah,
that's right. They're,
that they're the most serious arbiter of
things. Yeah. They're the grand judge.
Do Myself.
Beautiful thing about materials that you
get to listen to it on my iPhone or my,
um, my note, my galaxy note three has,
I've had have it for like maybe four or
five months and it might have hundred
and 50 sets on it. Oh Wow. Yeah.
And I can listen to all those sets
and then started the audience reaction
and gauge how it's working. So that's,
yeah, that's a similar idea
to it. To an editor, I mean,
an editor relationship with the writers.
Pretty, uh, pretty important obviously.
Because the one thing is you can't go
snatch your book off the shelves once it's
there. It's there. You
gotta live with how it is.
So you got to work as hard as you can
in this stage to make it as, I mean,
it's never going to be perfect.
There's going to be things about it
that you'll look at five years later and
just go, wow, why did I
do that? But each book,
I think each book probably just like each,
maybe one of your comedy cds is an
expression of that time in your life too.
And you got to let
it be that. Well there is that. Right?
You know,
out of the hundred and 50 sets,
maybe a hundred of them are from
like a year ago that I've got stored.
Like I take the MP three and I saved
them and then maybe 50 of them or so,
or over the last four or five months.
Okay.
And then what I'll do is never
listened to the old ones,
but always think that I'm going to
pack rat. I go, hold on to them.
But the most recent ones are the really
important ones, like a on this phone.
This is a new phone.
It only has Santa Barbara only as Friday
night show in Santa Barbara. That's it.
But eventually,
you know over the course of a few months,
it'll have a like a Wednesday night,
I'm at the Ice House,
I'll have that set on it.
I'll listen to that Thursday and I'll
break out the notebook and I'll listen to
it,
the headphones on,
and then my next set I'll add the notes
and then I'll try to figure out what I
did differently then it'll grow.
But the beautiful thing about
comedy is it has built in editors.
Yeah. Audience and also you can, you can,
there's no sense of it being on a shelf.
You, it evolves as you, as you, you know,
you work the act over and you work the
act over in it and it sort of becomes,
and we do that as much as we can.
You know,
that book probably went
through seven or eight edits,
but at at some point you got to just
say, well that's it. We're on a schedule.
You can over edit it too.
You can sort of rip sort of the rawness
and I'm sure you can probably do that in
a comedy act as well.
You can rip some of the stuff that is
really most important. And most the Ron,
if you take the rawness out of the rough
edges and you make it sort of smooth it
over and you listen to too many editors,
then you can't please everybody.
I think that's another thing too.
I've recognized it
self. Like you lose your vision of
what, what is good and what's bad.
Because I know as a comic
you certainly can, you Lou,
you listen to a joke so many times you
just like it gets means like it's just a
bunch of gobbly gook to you.
Totally. Yeah, totally. And that's,
I guess that's a danger that we both
faced in our separate, you know,
but very close, closely
related kinds of careers. Um,
so it's about listening to the right
and ultimately it's like listening cause
especially with horror,
you have someone, you know,
I've had plenty of emails and
I'm, no, you have to like what,
what kind of a person are you?
Kind of an awful creature.
What sort of primordial swamp pit did
you crawl out of to, you know, uh,
become who you are. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, absolutely.
I, you know, I'm not near that. I
mean, I'm not nearly in the public eye,
say as you are. I wouldn't have
to face that level of scrutiny,
but certainly in my small way, yeah, of
course I can make a tweet, just a joke.
Oh, and people will be bombarding
you. Oh, I'm sure. Yeah.
Long searching and trying to find
psychological cracks in your armor.
I wrote something, I thought
it was funny. Go Fuck Yourself.
Think about it for more than like,
you know what I mean?
But at the same point also, you don't
recant and be like, oh, well Geez,
I better change things because I wrote,
wrote,
um, just, I, I watched this woman,
she was on a date and she was talking
about how much she hates children.
And I wrote on Twitter that I view
women who don't like kids the same
way I would viewed dogs. I like
to eat their own shit and uh,
obviously got a reaction, which leaves
a lot of room for interpretation.
But this kind of wrote a whole blog
about all that. I only view women as,
you know,
being there to have children getting this,
I fucked up. I should have said
hate instead of don't like,
I was trying to be nice.
She should have been more definitive.
It was just based on one particular
and just this weird thing that I,
women who don't like kids
like, oh, get that kid away.
There's something gross about them.
I just, it's a weird thing. I've,
I find it very, uh, not just distasteful.
It's a weird way. Like
it's, it's disturbing.
It repels me when people like,
especially for whatever reason,
women hate, well love men
too. Now that I have kids,
I see a man who doesn't like kids who
hates kids and you think about all the
abuse that some children suffer a lot
of times because of people like that,
that hate kids, it becomes
very, uh, disturbing to you,
especially when you have kids of your own.
I'm,
I'm totally fine with like I have
friends who just don't want to have kids.
That's a different thing.
Totally. They're just like, we,
we want to be able to travel
and leverage that. I mean, yeah.
So do I love my son and I
know you love your kids too,
but um,
you know,
there's some points where me and my wife
looked at each other where, you know,
I mean, I don't know if you
had good sleepers but me,
it's like our kids a toddler now and
he's still doesn't sleep well, but man,
there were times like four o'clock
in the morning when he hadn't slept.
And I feel like I was just like,
there was some hellish fourth dimension
that it opened up that I was staring
straight into. And I just think, I think,
but then that's part of the rites of
passage of, of you, of you being a parent.
But if there's someone said,
I want to, anything to do
with that, I'm like, I don't,
I don't blame you man. Yeah, sure.
Go ahead. Take a pass on this one.
We definitely went through periods
where you didn't sleep, but I don't,
I just don't think there's anything cool
about shaming people that don't want to
have children. Oh No, there's, there's
people that feel like that if you,
if they have children, you know, there's
something special above and beyond.
A person doesn't have children. Like
you're never going to get it. You didn't,
didn't even grow up [inaudible]
side of it. Like, oh,
you really couldn't possibly understand
what, what we're talking about here.
So it's like, oh, play. This guy said
this to me once. This guy who was a, uh,
just a crazy man, he was a
fascinating dude, but he had kids,
they were all grown and uh,
one of them had been in and out of jail.
The other one smoked crack. And, uh,
he was mocking this guy who was this
musician friend of mine who was in his
fifties. He's like, I feel bad for
him. He's never had children. I said,
why do you feel bad for him?
He goes,
because he never figured out what life is
all about. Light procreating. I'm like,
you made criminals.
One of your kids or that do you?
No one smokes crack criminals.
Criminals are fucking dangerous.
They are in the morning I leave.
They haven't contributed anything to
the forwarding of, of, of our species,
but in his mind,
sure he was better.
He was better because he shot a live
round, do a woman. She shit out of kid.
Amazing.
Isn't it?
Now does that holier than thou moral high
ground that some people take when they
have children and I do.
You can contribute in amazing amounts
of society without ever having a child.
I think just as much.
It's a different sort of contribution.
There's nothing wrong with it.
And I,
I have a lot of friends that don't ever
want to have kids and they're great
people and I love them dearly. They love
you. You know what I mean? They love kids.
That's your thing. It's like
people who just, I hate kids.
I hate the idea of kids.
I don't like seeing them on airplanes.
I don't look like them in my airspace in
any way, shape or form is, first of all,
it's like go live under a rock because
I'm not not taking my kid out into the
sunlight because your don't like
them nearby. Are you a person?
Do you like people? Yeah. Well what do
you, how do you think they came from?
They come to see somebody make a
storage bin to existence as you know,
18 year olds or something. Yeah.
I just, for whatever reason,
I just think that there's some people
out there that can't make that connection
that like, oh, it's a baby
and the baby becomes an adult.
I certainly get it a lot
more now that I've had kids.
Like I like babies, like I see
babies. I think they're cute.
When I used to see babies before
I had kids, I was like, oh,
that fucking thing is going to start
screaming and I got to get out of here,
but I never hated him. No, no, exactly.
Yeah. People that do hate them,
I find them very disturbing.
And you have actually had people,
I'm wondering if I've ever run into
someone who like basically has said point
blank, I hate kids. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. There was a girl I dated.
He say that just that I
hate kids around them. They,
they, they always want too much
attention. I was like, wow.
I mean, and data for law. But she was,
she was angry about a lot of shit.
I think her parents were
alcoholics to over think.
It might've been a little bit of that. She
just, I don't know. Who knows? Who knows?
Who does know. Yeah. But I, but
I, I've, I've never heard it,
but I've have had people who are pretty
close to intolerance on that level as
well, you know? Um, and uh, and
I don't, I don't get it either.
And I certainly before I had kids,
yeah,
I'm more comfortable with
them now and I'm more,
I'm more like sympathetic towards other
people who are struggling with their kid
out in public. I'm like, Oh fuck. It's too
fine to, that is, you're more comfortable.
Just as a human being in life, you have
some success under your belt. You're not,
I mean, even though there is no
ultimate comfort, because look,
we're finite creatures on a finite planet,
finite solar system,
and if you don't live in the moment,
you're a fool because there,
there really is no tomorrow are crumbling.
Edifice is,
it's only as good as it is today and it's
not going to be as good tomorrow as it
was today. So Apollo creed in
rocky two nailed it. Or three,
three, four. Which one was that? There
is no tomorrow. Hmm. I'm just trying to,
I think he's threatened
by Mr too. Yeah, no,
he dies and full it for the
Russian. The Russian driver. Yes.
That's the rocky three doesn't want to
train. He's like, well, during the moral,
no,
tomorrow.
Tomorrow when he teaches him how to fight
like a black guy. Yeah, that's right.
I do remember that. Yes. Rocky three
but he's right. There is no tomorrow.
There's now and now goes on for long time.
But it doesn't go on forever.
The only reason why you think it's
tomorrow's because the earth is spinning.
You can mark it as tomorrow if you
really, you really into that. Oh yeah,
the winter definitely does come,
but there's no tomorrow.
So it's just this is this time.
You know what I mean?
We have a way of measuring it, but it's
really ultimately quite fruitless. Yeah,
I agree.
But there's something about it where it
becomes a completely overwhelming for
some people it did to defines their very
existence. You know, the passage of time,
the, I mean I wrote an article
for Esquire and it was about,
and you would have some knowledge of this
basically because it's, it's in MMA is,
is hormone replacement
therapy or testosterone TRT.
And um, and there's
this, there's this study,
it's called negligible senescence.
So senescence is what essence senescence.
Great, great, great. Word. Senescence
is, is what we're talking about.
Negligible Senescence,
n. E. S. C. E. N. C.
E I think.
And it's there,
it is negligible senescence and Senescence
is, is what you're talking about.
It's like our bodies just getting
older and things sort of slowly,
slowly crumbling and negligible.
Senescence is the study of creatures who
don't age the way that that humans do
like toward tortoises. That's right.
Exactly right. The digital Senescence,
you look up negligible senescence.
You see a turtle? Yup. That's right.
The look at the life to live.
It's shit. It is quite shit.
Yeah. Wander around. Fucking
birds pick their babies.
Have a fly off with them.
It's
perfect for a tortoise. The tortoise
doesn't know any different I guess,
but they did. They'd hate it. Yeah.
They would probably be
committing suicide those,
so they would be cutting their life
string short that way. But I think Wales,
certain whales have it. See
galls of all creatures. Muscles.
My fresh water pearl muscles live to be
250 years old and they don't and they
don't show this. That's the thing.
It's like a five year old muscle.
It acts the same as a 200 year old
woman. Must. How bout a cohort? A clam.
Do you know how old they get? No.
570 years old is the oldest one.
They found that old. Yup. I'd be
an enormous toward us 255 years.
Lobsters, a hundred plus years. Assumably
they don't really know until they get,
yeah. How about a hydro? Hydro is no,
it's kind of snake. Biologically immortal.
Biologically immortal. Immortal.
It's a genus of small, simple,
fresh water. Animals that
possess radial symmetry. A Hydra.
They're predatory animals belonging
to the phylum. Wow. Spell this.
C. N. I don't know why you'd put
a c and then it does not work.
Did you run out of vowels?
You Fuck? See, n I.
D a R.
I.
A S Darya and the class hydros.
Ah.
They can be found in most
unpolluted freshwater ponds,
lakes and streams in the temperate and
tropical regions and can be found gently
sweeping.
Oh by gently sweeping and
collecting net through weedy areas.
They are multicellular organisms,
which are usually a few meters long
and are best studied with a microscope,
but they are immortal. That's amazing.
What an interesting yeah. Phenomenon.
I never would've thought that enters
their lives. Shit. Yeah, that's the, yeah,
exactly. They're just a squiggle
around in the weeds. That's,
that's the punishment. Sorta be like,
hell yeah. It's like a reconstituted,
shitty child. Molesters become
hydras in their next life.
They just get swept up
and fucking dirty fish.
I'm not a mortal,
have a fishy to you.
But that started the idea of TRT is then
that the proponents say that, you know,
you're, you're, you're not going
to live forever. Of course,
that's not the body that we've been
gifted by, you know, by, by nature.
But you know, most when you talk to
guys, and I talked to guys. Yeah,
I used my father as, you know,
my dad's 65 now 66 and he's like,
I don't want to live forever.
Of course I just want to be able to be,
to carry groceries up
to my house when I'm 80.
I want to have that sort of quality
of life for as long as I can.
And then when that whole house comes down,
let it come down immediately.
You know what I mean? Well, that's
wishful thinking. It is quite honestly.
But you certainly can manipulate your
hormones to give you a decided advantage
over non manipulated people.
It becomes a real issue in mixed
martial arts because of course we, uh,
Brendan Schaub who a is on the podcast,
the fighter and the kid
with my friend Brian Cowen,
he's a fighter in the UFC and
he said it best and he said,
what's wrong with TRT when it comes to
competitive sports is that there's an
advantage of youth and
there's an advantage of wisdom
and wisdom comes with age
and with experience and with years and
years of study and practice and that,
that advantage sort of in some way
there's sort of a point of diminishing
returns where it cancels
out youth and experience,
whether it's at 35 or whether it's a
37 when does the tip back towards youth
again? Well, when you start supplementing
the hormones with testosterone,
it doesn't, and then you get guys
like Vito Bell for of course,
36 37 years old.
Fucking everybody up because they're got
muscles and the teeth now because he's
taking testosterone. What
about like Dan Henderson? See,
I feel like that's one where he's like
forced to go into like wars with guys who
are 15, even 20 years, his, his, uh,
younger than him and I feel like,
you know what I mean? But
that, but then you know,
people of the people that I grew up
watching as boxers didn't, you know,
you just had to keep throwing yourself
into that fray and if your body is
collapsing around you, that's the
choice that you've made. Well,
he's not on testosterone anymore
that it was abolished. It,
it's no longer allowed in the,
you are no longer alive and
most athletic commissions,
even worldwide have ceased. These
of it, Brazil stopped. So it becomes
really fucking interesting,
especially in Brazil because in Brazil
you can buy steroids and a lot of stores
you can buy them over
the counter like you can.
In Mexico you don't have
to have prescriptions.
I don't know if they've changed that in
Brazil. I know they have it in Mexico.
In Mexico, people go and buy like
fucking Viagara. They go by percosets.
They could buy all kinds of shit
down there. A lot. In a lot of ways,
but they just have different regulations
when it comes to pharmaceutical drugs
and, and, and, and steroids. Um,
but in the UFC you cannot
have testosterone replacement.
No one can have it anymore.
So it's really interesting also because
these people that have been taking it
for x amount of years,
they've depleted their system.
They've sort of shut their own
endogenous production down.
I think there's,
there's too many negatives to it.
There's too many negatives to it
as far as for athletic competition.
And one of the big ones is
I have a Dr. Mark Gordon,
who's a friend of mine who is a expert
on traumatic brain injury. And it says,
one of the big issues is you have to
find out what is it that's causing this
depletion of their natural source
of testosterone. Is it just old age?
Which is one possibility.
Another possibility is traumatic brain
injury and cutting their testosterone.
Absolutely. I never, well, he scared
the fuck out of me, man. His, uh,
his take on traumatic brain injury
is so studied and you know, he's,
he's been involved in assisting football
players and athletes of concussion.
Yeah. A lot of them
who have had, you know,
really dramatic changes because of head
trauma and the way he describes it,
it's like you never know what
it's going to be that does it.
It could be you go jet
skiing one day and you know,
just the bouncing on the water and
something's wrong and your brain and then
your body shuts down his testosterone,
your libido drops and you're not aware.
You just feel like you feel depressed.
The bottom dropped out of me or something.
And then you go to the
doctor, I'm depressed. They
put you on antidepressants.
I mean,
it's like,
and what he's finding is that the
pituitary gland is incredibly sensitive to
trauma.
And so obviously that when you're dealing
with a sport that one of the big goals
is to shut the brain down with
impacts, you know, with, with, uh,
a strike,
like giving them testosterone so that
it negates the effects of brain trauma.
Sort of like just masks the
real issue that's going on.
So it's not as simple as
their body getting older and
they need testosterone to
live in a nice quality of life.
It's a matter of medication that
sort of overrides this issue where,
you know, they're getting, they're getting
their brain fuck. Yeah. Yeah. So I think,
uh, and I also think it's too many. It's
too much possibility of cheating. Yeah.
I think there's that too.
I mean, I interviewed, um,
what's it, Keith Kaiser. Yes.
And he said that basically said the same
thing. It's just not. Um, and you know,
of course my editor wanted me to look
at the sports side of a thing and I did.
And I think there were some
really interesting stuff to be,
to be found on that side of it.
And I come down on,
on your side too.
I mean,
just like we've been having combat sport
events since Greek and Roman times.
Um, yeah. I mean, of course you don't want
to, some people would say, well listen,
we also fix MCL and ACL is, and we're
able to do great things with medicine. So,
you know what I mean?
Like why not take the advancement,
these benefits that we have and
if TRT is one of them, but I,
but I do think there's, there's the
fairness to the sport, but when I just,
before I left the hotel,
I saw commercial where it's like an
underarm now you just go in the morning,
you just swipe it on and
you had about your day.
So like just for not sports
taken out of it, just generally,
um, from my, what I've read
the research that I've done,
which was just in service of that
article, um, you know, I, I wouldn't,
I like I'm more or less said if my dad
wanted to use it, I would be like, listen,
if it works, uh, and if you try it,
you know what I mean? Uh, uh, you know,
and it makes some benefit to
your life. You know, I'd be like,
of course I'd be all for it.
It's really the tip of the iceberg when
it comes to manipulating the human.
This essentially a low level form of
genetic engineering and what you're going
to be able to do instead of introducing
these synthetic hormones into your
system,
which are going to be able to do,
is they're going to have nanobots that
repair tissue. They're going to have your,
your your body's ability to recuperate.
A lot of people don't understand what,
what hormones do and the,
the various different roles
that they play on your body,
but a hormone doesn't necessarily make
you bigger. What makes you bigger is it,
it makes you, when you take testosterone,
it makes you recover quicker.
And one of the ways guys can cheat is
that they can work harder and they can put
in more time because the recovery
is shorter because they take these,
these hormones and they can put in these
intense and insane sessions in the gym
and they'll be fresh as
a daisy in the morning,
whereas the other person has to sort of
will themselves to get up and through
hard work and determination can really
put in the time and get better the
traditional way. Um, so that, that's,
that's considered cheating. I agree.
Yeah.
But one day they're going to have fucking
male men who are on these nanobots.
That's right. Some form of genetic
[inaudible] man for 300 years,
cause he just keeps reject. That's
another thing I did. There's a guy,
Aubrey de grey. Yes. I
know that guy. Right. Okay.
So he basically just says that your whole
body can be replaced slow. And he says,
look at it like a car.
Yeah.
But I feel like there was some part of
me that thought just as a fiction writer,
like I don't know if I'd want
to see a 2000 year old person.
They smell like they smell.
They had like like old papery flesh shirt,
hot as fuck. What do they look
like? John Jamison in their prime,
but they smell like Barbara Walters so
you couldn't get rid of the century.
Kind of a would just be too,
too weird. Yeah, we're going to,
we're running out of time,
but that wouldn't be something that you
would really have to think about, man.
It was. If you get, if we get to a
pert, a point where people are a mortal,
there's going to be that thing
where they're like, they go, what's,
is there a next?
Should I just let this die off?
And there's going to be people that do
decide to just keep going and going,
but I feel like you'd lose all your
family and friends and all. Yeah.
You're all 2000 year old. You get annoyed
with each other for eternity. Yeah,
exactly. Listen, man, this is
a fascinating conversation.
I really enjoyed it.
Thank you very much. Let me know
when you're new book comes out.
What is it called again?
The deep. The dean. Yeah.
It's just like that movie
with Nick naulty. It is. Yeah.
Though the title's been used before,
but it's a different thing. All, well,
not entirely, but there's differences
and a, when can I get a copy of that?
I will make sure, wait, what
do you mean at the time?
Let's say six months at the most.
Six months from now. Mark it down.
All right. Thank you brother. It
was a lot of fun. No, my pleasure.
Thank you very much.
The book is called the troop and uh,
his name is not really nick cutter.
His name is Craig Davidson.
So if you like nick cutters work two t's,
why'd you go with two t's?
Because my agent cuter.
Yeah,
that would do that worked in a different
way. Yeah. Is unique near Nate.
Your agent came up with nick cutters. They
both came up with, oh, he thought like,
oh, they need to have like a hard
driving kind of like nick, you know,
shutter Bob Slasher. That's
right. My name's Nick Gutter.
My Bros, no filters. I cut him
off and I spit them liberals.
All right, thanks dude.
A lot of fun by the book.
It's available right now on amazon.com
but you will not get this covered.
Do you have an audio book version? An
audio book version as well? Uh Huh.
Beautiful. Go get it. You fucks.
And uh, thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to tango to rogan.ting.com get
yourself an awesome cell phone and save 25
bucks off of it.
Thanks also to one 800 flowers.com today
only Tuesday May 6th you can buy 18
vibrant multicolored roses and get a
free glass vase for 29 99 and for just 10
bucks more,
two dozen roses,
a glass vase and delicious box of
chocolates. How can you go wrong?
You cannot go to winning a hundred
flowers.com and enter in j r e or call
1-800-FLOWERS and mentioned j r e
thanks also to onnit.com that's o n n.
I t use the Codeword Rogan and save
10% off any and all supplements.
Tomorrow we'll be back with Tim Kennedy,
mixed martial arts superstar and
fascinating individual. And, uh,
then, uh, we got, we got a lot of podcasts
coming up, folks. A lot of good shit.
All right. Much love.
See you soon. Big Kiss.
Hmm.